boneless or bone
bone
[Music]
you're not eating the [ __ ] bone
marrow go on you're not cracking
you're like you're not in the bone the
bone does do [ __ ] it does oh my [ __ ]
ghost
welcome back
welcome back
welcome
welcome to this episode
silence i'm doing the intro
welcome to this episode of trash taste
i'm with the boys joey and god and i'm
connor or monkeys people call me okay
connor suffered from a major cramp in
his neck yeah
i had like a my life flashed before my
eyes like 10 minutes ago i thought i was
here my neck was gone we were about to
start recording and then connor had a
cramp in his neck and i'm just like man
can you get any more like boomer than
you already are
is your body already feeling it are you
getting your like nerfs already man
maybe i'm dying already
i mean actually i mean actually like i
have recently started to like stretch
every day after like work like just just
at home like you know i would go home
and just do like really simple like 10
to 15 minute like stretch exercises how
did this start
it started because i found myself
sitting at my desk all day or sitting
you know on a set like this all day and
then i would get up and go oh
that's a sharp pain in my lower back
that's not normal i want to make fun of
you but you know i can't make fun of you
if you're taking care of yourself
exactly oh yeah and you're coming from
but as a friend you had a massive crap
but as a friend i want to call you a
boomer and ask you when you want your
diaper changed yeah right like it's
scary like i think like i think to
myself nah i'm not that at that stage
yet yeah but then i realized next month
i'm 27 i'm like you know what i'm kind
of getting to that stage i should
probably start while i'm ahead you know
to just like fix my [ __ ] before it gets
too messed up honestly i feel like a lot
of people especially when you're just in
your [ __ ] 20s you just don't give a
[ __ ] about this i mean why would you you
never feel any effects on your body you
do [ __ ] that your body was not built to
do yeah you don't realize this but like
you don't realize this until you like
that kind of time period of your life
comes to an end that you just realize
man that's a that's a really short time
period of my life and i've just got the
rest of my life now having to live with
this problem because i just didn't
[ __ ] take care of it so yeah take
care of your body like if there's one
thing that i've definitely paid
attention to especially like it doesn't
matter if you're a youtuber or you're
just at an office job somewhere where
you're sitting at a desk for a long
period of time please please google
ergonomics it's really [ __ ] important
and it's a really boring word but my god
like ergonomic
like every time i set up a new desk now
i have to like make sure it's just
ergonomically correct because i didn't
realize this until not even when i was a
youtuber but like i like a year of
working an office job and just my my
screen was just slightly off and like it
was slightly off center i had to like
tilt my neck just just just to look at
it and it like you know it's it's
something that i didn't really care
about until like a year came past and
then my neck really [ __ ] started in
anatomy me when i have to tilt my neck
one percent less than i'd like
you will die now
yeah it's like you've made me kill my
neck one degree more than i'd have liked
to you know what this means
every day it increases by another degree
as retaliation i will bend your back one
degree every day no but that's the thing
right it's like i've also realized very
quickly since we have the standing desks
here yeah i've because for the longest
time i thought like standing this was
just like a you know like a what it's a
myth
it's like a fad i was like come on like
this is just like a new thing that's
happening it's like oh people are health
conscious whatever but the moment i
started using i'm like oh okay this
actually makes so much of a difference
because i just i just like the noise it
makes
i like the thing they go
there's something nice about it
but but it's so i realized very quickly
especially between working here in the
office and working at home where i don't
have a standard currently i mean i
bought a standing desk recently because
i realized actually how much of a
governor's standing
i literally did i was like wow actually
after using it i realized why this is
such a big thing and why so many
youtubers are getting it because it
actually makes so much of a difference
yeah like i i never it's it's so weird
because especially like when you're in
university right you hear about these
things that adults do to increase
productivity and i'm just like just work
better just work harder and then like i
don't know when it happened but then
like
i just noticed that my productivity just
dropped because of this thing that i
never really thought about like having a
standing desk
for some reason it just
helps your productivity when you're
standing and you just need a change in
posture or changing whatever exactly i
i'm pretty lying to myself when i feel
like it makes me more productive i feel
like i just wanted to spend money and be
like look it's productive look guys
look my desk move
i'm productive now yeah it's like no i'm
not i'm lazy stuff yeah yeah
or at least my definition of blazing
yeah yeah i mean i cannot work i mean i
remember for the longest time i just
worked from my bedroom and i'm just like
i don't know how i did that i i did that
for two years
there's people doing things that yeah
isn't me and it's it's intense
yeah i can't do it i remember i tried
once to edit a video at a coffee shop
and i just felt way too like
self-conscious because i'm in the back
of my head i'm thinking like these
people must think i'm so weird looking
editing a video of myself i can't i
can't just treat this place like my
workstation either right there's too
much stuff out there yeah it's not it's
not my [ __ ] area it's i can't rip a
massive fast if i'd like to see
sometimes you just need to get out of
the space that you've seen for like
every day of your life
yes huh touching grass yeah yeah so yeah
you're basically touching grass except
you're just drinking coffee with a bunch
of strangers who you're never gonna see
again how do you not just constantly
keep buying coffee
that's
you don't i just keep buying coffee
right yeah i think that's the whole
reason why people work at coffee shops
how much coffee do you drink anyway
connor your next present machine is
[ __ ] dying it's just
good so i can buy the upgrade
no more please
i would find myself buying like eight
[ __ ] starbucks is i under the menu at
the back of my hand i'll be like a a
tour guide who will come to starbucks
with me i'll be like no don't get that
it's just
i i just i know i'll spend like
dollars a day on coffee if i go to
starbucks and work there i know cause
like i i've i don't drink that oh i do
drink coffee see i do i drink yeah you
drink it so [ __ ] fast and i don't
know how like you're drinking like i
think you drink it extraordinarily slow
just i i think i drink it's like you're
making love to the [ __ ] coffee i
think he drinks it at a normal place
you don't get a normal place yeah you
probably drink it i drink it slowly i
drink fast but he drinks it
i feel like
there's three wolves here
what was it [ __ ] uh
[ __ ] uh completely different three pigs
three pigs
three musketeers three walls
a totally different childhood story
there
completely off
we're just blowing our houses and the
big bad pig came out
look i'm saying it's it's most
economically efficient to drink your
coffee and just eat your food slowly
right because you have more time to
enjoy it because because like what
happens when you finish your coffee then
you just feel like you have an empty you
feel like you have a hole because you're
like you're assuming my happiness and my
enjoyment of the meal is tied at my
speed or or the amount of time it exists
on the table that doesn't [ __ ] matter
i'm just gonna eat it that's what that's
what i like when i stop eating it the
joy is gone i don't savor the joy the
slower i take it that's absurd what are
your [ __ ] speed runner no no
but like i don't get enjoyment out of
being like having one bite and thinking
damn that's a good bite
sometimes you've got her injustice yeah
you gotta say
sometimes i do but when it's starbucks
it's it's like it's like being like i'm
savoring a wipe of my ass cheek i've had
so many starbucks i'm not gonna savor it
it's a [ __ ] starbucks like i think
that's why you [ __ ] drink eight
coffees a day or whatever you're an
espresso machine is a [ __ ] battered
war veteran at this point like you just
got back from world war ii man
i think i think i i never knew it was
possible for coffee machines to have nam
flashbacks
i saw yours i get value out of it every
time you turn on the button it's like oh
whether you like it or not
i love an espresso i i can't help it
yeah we know we know yeah i just love it
man i love the taste of dirt in my mouth
do you not like find yourself just being
like
maybe it's too many coffees no
why i don't know why would i i don't
know like okay so you obviously like the
taste of coffee yeah i love the taste of
coffee okay so why not just drink decaf
no
hahaha
i know this is a controversial thing to
ask but i have to make sure i have to
make sure it's just you know half of the
if the caffeine doesn't work for you
what's the difference
it does work but it's numbed but the
kick that you get when you drink it is
the same you sound like a drug
i mean i mean i probably is i mean i'm
just drunk i'm actually on a corner
slide here because
not regarding coffee but like for
example i like the taste of beer and
wine okay have you ever had
non-alcoholic beer wine
oh my god it is it's hard
it's like the coffee what makes it so
great is that that first sip in the
morning is just beautiful like it's such
a kick
i agree and i keep getting that every
single cup
so i keep coming back every 10 minutes
is another morning
it's a never-ending morning no because
going back to like being able to work in
a coffee shop don't like
i find it so hard to just work by myself
in my room sometimes like i just like
the feeling i get distracted
by yourself yeah yeah i get distracted
by my own thoughts sometimes yeah i
don't know sometimes i just like having
an atmosphere where just it's just
people doing stuff and people doing [ __ ]
which is why like i love working in the
office now when there's people here
because it's like i like that too
because we were all working though yeah
exactly yeah but when we're at the
coffee shop i feel like
you know i'm kind of it's like that one
guy who won't stop talking about
transformers at the party i feel like
i've just brought something to an area
where
what kind of parties are you going to
like let me tell you i feel like i i'm
intruding on the atmosphere of the
location even though i know i don't give
a [ __ ] when someone is working at a
starbucks but i feel like i'm i'm doing
something weird when i'm working at a
starbucks well i've i've always been
that person that like even like during
school i could never study on my own i
had to study with other people otherwise
i just wouldn't focus i used to be but
then i swapped i don't know why really
yeah i like flip-flop between the two i
can do either but if i do one for too
long then i just i need i need i need
like sometimes you gotta change up your
routine right because if you did like a
full day of studying with your friends
you only really did like three hours of
studying
yeah but that's three hours more than
doing it on my own yeah but so i feel
like i do 12 hours with my friends where
six of it uh hey have you seen this
funny youtube video oh yeah and then
three hours has actually started oh yeah
yeah yeah when i do on my own it's like
four hours of solid studio see i i can't
do that
because like even like even when i'm at
home in my office and i'm like okay i
have to get [ __ ] done i can't just sit
down and work for three hours straight
it depends how how severe the stuff is i
need to get done i never i never find
myself in that situation when the stuff
i need to get down is like i it needs to
get done today i'll get it done today oh
yeah
if it's something but if it's like oh
you know this video is coming out like a
deadline's not coming up it'll be it'll
be pleasant
yeah i just think there is just too many
distractions on my work computer
unfortunately yeah laptop doesn't have
those attractions no because okay when
when
it's it's like it's like exercising at
home versus exercising at the gym right
because in theory i don't know about
that no no no no
i think it is because like in theory in
theory if you exercise at home it's a
lot more efficient right if you just buy
a home gym you can just exercise at home
you can [ __ ] buy we fit you should
you should like lose weight losing
weight but like when you go to the gym
everyone around you is there for a
purpose or is just doing something it
sounds like you want an office
[Music]
it sounds like you want to go to an
office well so yeah well i mean that's
why we have this stuff
you still want a coffee shop now or is
it here um i i still work at coffee
shops okay sometimes i don't think that
that comparison is comparable i cause
you know a gym
your home has
more
of the correct equipment that you need
to work you have the cameras you have
the mics you have
as a youtube you have everything you
would need for a desktop you have the
ergonomics your starbucks doesn't have
the yoga yes and you know i've seen some
of those stuff sometimes they're busy
man you can't get the ideal chair you've
got to certainly show shitty stools
not if you go first thing in the morning
that's that's the way that's the way
you're going right you can't just watch
so i could get clock in before everyone
else
that's this is how you know i've like
worked in a coffee shop like i know
i know the peak optimal time to go to
starbucks to get the seat that i want
and the seat that i want is like right
in the corner it's got it's got a out
power outlet as well so you can just
work there all day um and it's just
perfect you you have enough of an
atmosphere where you don't get
distracted by the people around you but
it's but you still get the nice i can
just imagine god lining up first thing
in the morning 6am this guy must really
want to call him everyone everyone else
on the business shoots with their
macbook waiting for their frappes
honestly you can't go during lunch time
or any time past 4 p.m here because then
it's just too much too many people but
anytime outside of that you get free
choice i've never been to the starbucks
yeah and it hasn't been busy as far as
like if if your job for example if if
the kind of content that you did didn't
always require a camera right or you
know
sometimes a lot of the videos you do
is just pure research right when you're
researching things to buy and you know
stuff like that i feel like you can do
that kind of work in a coffee shop and
have a change of an environment but i
could also do that at home but that you
can you could do that
what i'm arguing is that
you know if you need something to be
more productive i feel like a changing
environment really does [ __ ] help i
get so frustrated because you know i'm
using a laptop and i'm like [ __ ] i wish
i had my keyboard i always had my mouse
you know like i start getting frustrated
that's not as fast as how it is right
i'm like i can do it way faster at home
see i'm like
to me to me i've i've i i get what you
mean but then some because i'm too used
to working at home sometimes like the
smallest thing can just
distract me it's just like if it's not
like perfectly optimized or perfectly
optimally
if something's not optimal then it would
just like distract me i also don't want
to wear a mask when i'm working
yeah i just want to be home this day and
age it's a little more of a pain in the
ass yeah i just oh man you know i just
don't want to work with them like on a
laptop for like a few hours with my mask
on i'm like go home and work yeah
exactly and breathe
[Music]
and you know also going back to the gym
comparison you know again as i was gonna
say like the gym has all the equipment
you'd want your home is never gonna be
as stacked as the gym unless you have
like a private gym in your house even
then right like you won't get the you
won't get the cringey playlist you know
all of these things add you know either
water machine cringy playlist cringy
playlist yeah you know the the justin
bieber baby that comes on occasionally
what starbucks are you going to no no no
i enjoy the the pit bull that comes on
repeat that's what you know it's four
o'clock right it's like evanescence yeah
they would like they would play the same
songs i loved it i don't know why but
also you know you get you uh there's
just so much more at the gym there's so
many more facilities and you're and the
coffee shop doesn't have any facilities
you're downgrading whereas the gym
you're you know the argument to go to a
gym is that you can unequivocally get an
upgrade in equipment and you also get
the environment um so i think that
comparison full short sadly gone changed
my mind well the thing is right because
i feel like atmosphere is important and
it's not all about equipment
if if if equipment was all that mattered
especially when it's working
then everyone would need [ __ ] three
screens and a gamer pc to make videos to
make youtube friends
but that's not the case as somebody who
used to make his videos on uh 300 laptop
i can tell you i need the pc yeah i i
need it i like 12 hour render times i
find a mistake [ __ ] no man i can't do
that no i'm not i'm not saying you need
to you can do everything in the coffee
shop but i'm saying if you need a
changing environment get out your house
sometimes touch some grass i swear to
god it would help it'll help your
productivity it'll help it'll help
bottom line are you telling me are you
telling me that that apex logo in the
corner doesn't [ __ ] taunt you i don't
know every time you have like five
minutes and you're just like
maybe i could play a game do you think
you can play apex in starbucks uh no you
can't you could have that would be true
powerful
you know i'm not a slave to work
sometimes i can i can slack off for an
hour and play apex you know nothing
wrong with that you know it's a break
privilege you know uh i want to
you know also
when you want to take a take a toilet
you know sometimes you got to worry
about oh my bag my stuff's here i don't
know how to pack it all up
in japan i know i know but also like any
other country i'd be like yeah but like
i've got to do so also yeah but it's a
bit different when we go to the toilet
when you go to the toilet because you
take an hour and you're in the toilet
and and i feel like you're tempting fate
you're really pushing japan's limits on
what will be stolen yeah it probably
won't be but now
i'm five minutes i'm in and out it's
fine no god made a big deal but also i
also like being able to fully immerse
myself in the toilet experience and i
feel like i can't do that in the public
toilet you know what i mean
what
do you what i can't
in terms of [ __ ] right oh my god we're
[ __ ] talking about shits again
in public because i need my own private
space
you can't go to the toilet in public
number two why i like it's it's like a
last resort right
what what why because because i want my
own private space right i wanna i wanna
what are you doing you [ __ ] on me
he's making art what are you doing what
are you doing okay okay i don't want a
time limit to how long i need to sit on
the toilet again
i don't give a [ __ ] when i wave someone
i understand sometimes you you have to
take the time you take yeah i'll
complain about it someone takes ten
minutes of [ __ ] yeah i don't give a [ __ ]
he can take him 10 minutes to take a
[ __ ] well he doesn't want to be
complained about that's the point
i'm going to mutter under my breath when
i sit down
i don't want to feel pressured you know
i i i hate it when i feel like just
don't feel pressured just don't you
don't feel pressure you can't it's not a
see-through door you can't see the
[ __ ] line you're [ __ ] yourself
we've all been there we've all been
there you're [ __ ] desperate for the
toilet and you're like you're [ __ ]
searching for any public toilet you can
maybe you're in a starbucks maybe you're
in a train station right and you go to
this order and there's just this one guy
who's just taking three millennials as
much as he's taking you every time
he's [ __ ] here i don't want to be
that guy that's why i'm just like no i'm
doing it
oh there's gone again i want to have a
comfortable experience and i understand
that comes it might take a little more
time than i'd like right i understand
that comes with the fact that someone
else is going to want a comfortable
experience i don't have to wait i don't
give a [ __ ] literally i don't i will
wait to give that [ __ ] i i will wait the
five minutes to ten minutes whatever it
be yeah yeah i'll be like [ __ ] [ __ ] why
don't you taste something but you know
at the end of the day i don't give a
[ __ ]
you have some very i mean
what a big man what a big man like
you have some really [ __ ] weird
toilet habits that okay so before before
we start recording kind of kind of goes
into the toilet joey yeah right and he
goes
do you sit down when you pee and i'm
just like
what i'm mixing
i do
do you have a penis
isn't that isn't the whole point of
being a man is so you can get your
god-given right to pee standing up and
you choose to sit down i sometimes sit
down whenever oh oh god bro i got like
big ass cheeks sometimes it's just it's
like it's [ __ ] bidets have rotted
your guy's mind no no no no no
no no no no no no hear me out the reason
why i sometimes sit down to pee is
because when you're standing up you're
contracting right
or for one you can't check your life
it's literally five seconds ten seconds
no
who cleans the toilets in his own house
i don't want to clean that [ __ ] when
you're wearing shorts and you pee right
if it's like if there's like a 30
centimeter difference between where your
your pee pee is and the toilet there's
gonna be splashbacks yeah if you're
wearing shorts you'll feel it on your
legs exactly so when you're going into a
toilet and there's a urinal there do you
just sometimes go to
the public the public yeah if it's a
problem yeah because someone wants to
sit down yeah sometimes i've been
walking around for so long i'm just
[ __ ] exhausted bro
there are no benches in japan right so
the next best thing is a toilet this is
the most unoptimized way to go to the
toilet ever like that you should be
against this you're literally spending
more energy to sit down pee than it is
just like two birds one stone it's like
what
about
i don't immediately get back up i'm on
my phone for like five minutes i'm just
scrolling this is the best phone
and you're criticizing him for taking an
hour to [ __ ]
you take five minutes to pee no not
actually five minutes but like i i play
my phone a little bit maybe play some
angry birds you know some cut the rope
you know the classics i've got doodle
jumps
you know how it is you know but no you
actually genuinely take 30 minutes of
[ __ ] i don't think that's yeah i i
actually
genuinely i haven't we get to the point
in this office where i legitimately go
where's god yeah we got where's gone and
we realized he's been gone for 30
minutes did he go to the shops or
something no he's taking a [ __ ] okay but
like i'm actually i'm i'm not just
sitting there for no reason okay
what part of this just take can you
explain which aspect takes 30 minutes
i'm generally are you performing like
alchemy in there like why is it taking
so long i know some sometimes like i
just feel uncomfortable if i don't feel
completely empty like like like like i
need to feel completely empty before i
feel comfortable stopping the process
right
no it's the [ __ ] stupidest [ __ ] what
are you talking about sometimes you're
just not going to empty out man you just
gotta get on with it you're gonna be
sitting back you're literally gonna be
sitting there all day just go back
completely
like you don't have a limit to how many
shits you can take a day you know like
you can if you you take a [ __ ] you get
up and you go oh i just come back about
an hour later you're like oh i'm a bit
full again you can't go back yeah but
why do you have to like why do you have
to have to be like this is the only [ __ ]
i can take for the day i'm going to
empty out when i try
like like it's like you're not a dog
you've nerfed yourself you've nerfed
yourself i nerfed myself i i have that
feeling right where i'm not fully empty
i'm like
shogunite get on with the dead man i'll
come back later in fact i think like two
to three shots a day on average yeah me
too me too just because like i know like
i'm just like in and out if i'm still
full it's all right i'll be back in the
night you can tell within like two
pushes if it's common enough
not like you don't want to strain that
you're like you're you don't need to
wait you're depraving a good [ __ ]
experience bro you're okay i'm sorry
your ass muscle is probably the
strongest [ __ ] thing it exists the
amount you've probably worked that thing
out it's probably insane i'm probably
crushed someone's head with your anus
man jesus christ
you know i'm i'm i'ma [ __ ] say
sometimes the shits are the highlights
of the day like like like like some
sometimes you just need a [ __ ] escape
like are your days okay i want days of
[ __ ] good man
[ __ ] are you kidding me sometimes you
just need to escape from your man cave
you just need to go on your twitter like
like i just imagined it he's just eight
hours in the starbucks [ __ ] vain
bursting at his head he's like
i gotta go and [ __ ] but i gotta go home
i can't do it here it's gonna take one
hour
this is the black hole that's warming in
his [ __ ]
like i won't do anything to like to like
hold it so like so i can get back home
and just get in my comfortable space
right
you have okay okay like some some of
like
some of the best ideas i swear to god
some like human human civilization would
be like 50 less civilized if
people didn't have a space to [ __ ] in
comfortably i swear to god some of the
best ideas come on the toilet i'm not
[ __ ] crazy okay god listen if you
spend a majority of your day on the
toilet yes most of your ideas are gonna
be on the toilet so that's that's that's
where that's coming from
what i'm saying is the toilet is just a
comfortable place with zero distractions
you're just free with your own thoughts
and the only place that really that the
only the only place you're in it sounds
like you voluntarily put yourself in
prison for 30 hours also it's like like
how much more chaotic is like other
explosions happening in your room like
what
like how much more how much more
relaxing could it be compared to your
own room i'm sorry it's it's it's like
there's there's two spots that you just
can't take away from me my [ __ ]
toilet where i can [ __ ] at my shower
where can i where i can take 40 minutes
showers as well it's 40 minute showers
this meant morning routine you know you
know those influences you're like i get
gonna
up
at
5
[ __ ] god's like i get up at 5am i take a
shower 7am i take a [ __ ] 9am i'm ready
to work
literally it's like interesting honestly
after after that 40 minutes you have the
most productive hour of your life man i
swear to [ __ ] god
40 minute showers you know africa would
be a first world country if you didn't
take showers that long
jesus christ
what up is your boy joey why am i
excited you asked well it's because this
episode of trash taste is sponsored by
box boxer is a monthly snack box
subscription service that delivers
original assortments of premium japanese
snacks and tea pairings boxer is not
just a premium snack subscription
service by the way but a way of getting
to know japanese culture and as the only
nippon jin on this podcast i pride
myself in you guys
knowing japanese culture first time
boxing customers will receive the
seasons of japan box so they could get a
taste of the snacks per season and
shipping to the us is free this month
boku has their moon box theme in the
name of the moon boxu will punish you
with great snacks that are moon themed
look at this potato snack corn potage
flavor and let me drop a fun nippon fact
on you even though the word potage is a
french word the whole concept of corn
potage as a flavor is actually quite
unique to japan actual japanese dish
corn portage is a seasonal dish that we
eat here from june to october get all
these japanese snacks with alco trash
taste 10 link is in the description to
get 10 off your boxes subscription thank
you to the boxer for sponsoring this
episode back to the show this is one
thing in japan as well that i [ __ ]
despise i know i think god's house has
it
so there's a thing that you could buy
and i've never seen it in the uk i don't
know if it's a thing elsewhere in japan
you can buy like these uh cushioned
toilet seats oh yeah yeah you can buy
cushions to go on your toilet yeah yeah
and it's probably the most vile thing
i've ever experienced yeah and gaunt and
sydney [ __ ] bought one okay okay
don't don't don't group me in there and
like like this okay
explain yourself
no i'm not i'm not explaining myself
because you know sometimes when it's
when you go you go to a house right and
you can tell who the single people are
and you can tell who the people who are
either it's a woman's room or it's like
it's like a couple yeah i don't know any
guy in the world who would actually buy
a fluffy thing to place on there
it's like a fluffy carpet yeah on on
your toilet seat yeah where you put your
sweaty butt cheeks on a hot summer's day
yeah and i was just like what well i'm
going to sit on this guy god's cheeks
he's been there 40 minutes well i mean
you know with the amount of [ __ ]
hours he's sitting on a hard surface he
probably needs to [ __ ] cushion his
arms probably replicate gone from the
dna in that carpet on the toilet you
know
i just i just to me it's so disgusting i
don't know why because you you
you know i don't want fabrics near like
a toilet bowl it's warringly close to
the butthole i don't i don't like i
don't like it either is there a reason
why it was purchased
honestly did you did you push back at
all were you like no
honestly i woke up one day i went to the
toilet and i was like cindy what the
[ __ ] is this thing living on our toilet
seat
and i tried to get it off but it's glued
on
no no
no
so i'm just like it's so bad i hate it
so much
sure in the winter
maybe i can understand the purpose of it
you don't want a cold toilet see i got
it it's not that good but it is it is
like
toilet seats it is the most disgusting
thing in summer you have to sit on a
fair it also you know when it's not even
my toilet i get a guard's house i want
to use god's toilet [ __ ]
this feels like this feels like you know
when they designed the homeless benches
to be like you can't sleep on them yeah
it felt like that it was like a toilet
seat designed so no no
[ __ ] on it because it's like why would
you want to rub the carpet that guards
put his ass
into your ass cheeks so disgusting of
course japan would come up with
something like that yeah of course i
mean it's it's wonderful
it's
so gross
[Music]
next it's gonna be gone
i'm
there are just certain items which you
would never just there are certain items
i find that you would just never see in
like in a guy's place or just a guy like
a bachelor pad for example yeah like um
like i don't trust any guy who buys
candles right
uh i buy candles
actually
yeah oh my god what's wrong i love
candles man they're great stress
relievers i mean they're great
wait wait you like you buy candles
because you like baths right i love
baths okay that's that's that's the
reason that's that's the [ __ ] reason
i i don't i i'd say i take a shower like
just a shower without a bath combo maybe
once a month really i don't i just bath
every day damn so how often how often do
you use your candles
my candles well um right now obviously
uh they're moving i haven't really been
using them yeah i just think normally i
used to like light it like twice a week
twice a week twice a week in like do you
have one for like each room no just my
office oh just your office okay okay i
don't really near my bed i don't trust
it it might just like spill i just like
like i i i like having a nice scent in
my room but there's just something about
candles and just having an open flame
somewhere in your room that just makes
me really uncomfortable dude
[ __ ] candles and throughout the house
i'm like everywhere i look as a
firehouse i know i know right now
i i never put a candle in a room that
i'm not in
i would never do that oh yeah no see i'd
never light a candle while i'm not in
the room yeah i i could scare shitless
when i'm like working all day and then i
go to the we live in japan yeah go to
the earthquake
yeah yeah and i go to the bedroom and
there's like three candles lit up and
i'm like what what do you want this room
to smell like
when you go to bed yeah it's fair but
not when you're not in the bedroom which
is dangerous i mean smells good don't
get me wrong but it's like one is enough
yeah where did when did you start buying
that now i got really into it i used to
go on like candle subreddits for like
candle recommendations
what i swear this has happened in the
time period that i started to know you
because i was like i went to your place
and i've never seen yeah i got really
into it in london i uh i had like four
candles in my bedroom was it [ __ ]
xena that got you into it no no i i was
the candle guy
i was all me
i bought one candle at the store one day
and i thought this is good but it could
smell better and then i i looked for a
scent that i thought would be better
yeah and i found one i liked um and i
started like learning what gives a good
uh a good scent you know a lot of them
don't really do good scents you know
like the very you know when you sniff it
and uh like floral ones and uh like
grassy type smells they don't [ __ ] do
anything like when you when you burn
that [ __ ] it's not gonna last right
there's a few that like like the really
strong like fruit ones like cherry and
stuff that'll stay in your room for like
a week i just i just i just want to know
like okay so you got into candles for
the sense right yeah why not buy like
one of those
something that's not a candle so i i do
uh try the uh
yeah
there's air fresheners they don't do
[ __ ]
[Music]
okay i [ __ ] with incense yeah
so the burning ones are good as well i
like those the burning ones are good for
like if you need an instant hit like
yeah if you just need it if you just
need to make no it's true
shut the [ __ ] up actually
you're totally right the internet sticks
when you burn them are much better for
like an instant like you want to cleanse
the room yeah yeah yeah yeah nice clean
scent yeah and you say smokey it's not
smokey it's it's got the nice charred
scent to it that really helps it's just
it's very relaxing yeah it's very
relaxing i can see why you know every
every [ __ ] massage place has one yeah
i like the uh i find that the the oil
ones are very good if you want to have a
like 24 hour one for like uh you know
like maybe two weeks tops i i i think
the oil ones are the best and i i like
and i feel like a lot of guys don't
really consider sense
oh i i have one and
the only like the only reason i did was
because i started dating someone and
then and then i'm just like this is uh
this actually smells actually uh make
the room feel good
who [ __ ] knew right i have one in my
living room bedroom and office yeah
because i just want to have every i
won't have every room centered but i'm
just like why why use candles when you
have the oil sticks or the incense
because candles are aesthetic candles
are more of a you know if you really
want to feel like you're relaxing the
flame along with it's like a fireplace
it's it's it's a safe fireplace yeah you
know
not in japan japan you can't get a
fireplace in japan so the next best
thing is because candles don't make you
know there's if you're [ __ ] stressed
as [ __ ] i can't an open flame next to
the carpet are you kidding me like in
japan
one little earthquake in the end bye bye
apartment trim trim the wick to the
right size make sure it's not burning
too aggressively make it burn slowly the
[ __ ] are you talking
i had like specific scissors for
trimming wicks why are you serious yeah
because i used to buy big cats oh you
never talked to them how am i just
finding out i just like
it's just candles in it it's nothing not
a big deal
i just i i have like for a guy
for a guy i used to buy so occasionally
i'd buy like those like yankee candles
that's like that's like i've just gotten
into candles cam yeah i mean these are
basic [ __ ] candles you know what i mean
this is babies first i'm i'm getting are
you really about to gatekeep campbell
honestly no no no no no he's he's a
candle connoisseur because the yankee
candles
you get very uh very artificial scents
and you get like you can get like big
ones and you get like a good value for
money but the problem is that because
they're so big they're like this [ __ ]
big after like
uh one week or two days of using it
they're [ __ ] gorgeous tunnels right down
it's a candle turn by the way tunneling
you wouldn't understand if you went into
it
no but like so it goes right down and
you have to like but depending on how
you burn it you can't just keep burning
it otherwise it will just dig down so
you have to like you have to be smart
you buy like custom-made candles
i really like them when you go to there
were some candle stores in london that
did really nice candles really expensive
but man the scents were so nice and you
would get like really nice spreading
sense a lot like i said like i'd say
half of the candles out there like that
you can get an amazon [ __ ] don't do
anything they're just lazy they just
burn and then you're like i can't smell
[ __ ] yeah great like the the scent
should be strong but not last too long
no i'm i'm part of the incense master
race that that is good
to me
i i both have their place
nothing to me can beat an incense and to
me candles are just like the middle
church yeah
i wonder why
i got was in the dictionary in
the sense i like these two
[Music]
one of like the most surprising tangents
we've ever gone on trash taste i swear
i've mentioned i like candles before no
you've never never you've never that's
why we're freaking out neither on trash
taste or in real life
this is real life joey also it's great
you know you you can eat i'm easy to buy
gifts for you can just buy me a nice
couch i wish i [ __ ] knew that she's
got a nice candle cause every time i'm
like well [ __ ] he has everything jojo
related i literally can't get him
anything anymore but now i know you like
candles so i'll just get your [ __ ]
candle give me an expensive candle a
nice one don't give me a chance yeah but
now you have to get a candle that
impresses him yeah oh great
don't get me i don't like candles that
are like carved into shapes that's a
load of nonsense you're just tacking on
values and nothing get me a good candle
you know what i mean like i just
yeah i mean that's uh there's a lot of
nice channels out there shout out to the
local candle makers in your area if
there is one you probably make good
candles what do you guys think of like
scented soaps and like homemade stuff
i've got i know you're gonna say i mean
i mean i i'm only mentioning this
because it's because like sydney sydney
recently really got into meeting making
custom-made soaps and you know they
honestly honestly i'm i'm kind of sold
they i like the smell they look good
they look aesthetic
the only problem with like custom-made
and scented soaps is that they look
great when you just get them when
they're like us when it starts to melt
when it's like a square block it looks
so aesthetic it looks great and then you
use it for like two weeks and like
shit's falling out of it yeah like she
puts like fresh flowers in it and it
looks [ __ ] amazing until the flowers
start [ __ ] falling off and
falling in the sink
i really like the
like uh the haunted syrup i don't know
when i started preferring it to
like uh like the pump soaps the hand
soap uh hand soap and body i like i like
the bricks oh i don't like the body
soaps you don't no no no i feel like it
really gets on your body i feel like it
really deep cleans you as opposed to
like the uh just like liquid soaps that
you get it depends what i love about
liquid soaps is that it feels like it
just coats your body
but like the hand soap really gets in
there and you can get some real nice
scents it just feels rough it feels
rough no that's what i like it feels
like it's really [ __ ] clean and i
feel like i've dead i've never thought
that that deep i feel like
joey's just sitting here being like i'm
just like doesn't wash my body yes
you can get like soaps with like
uh i'm going off on one today i don't
know yeah you can get like soaps with
stuff in them that is like little uh
coarse material so that even when it's
like you're we're going away it feels
quite coarse i do like if we're talking
about specifically i do like the kind of
charcoal yeah so it's kind of like it's
kind of like scratchy against your skin
yeah it feels like so it really gets in
your skin yeah so you don't feel like
you're losing grip as well yeah so you
can just kind of like go ham yeah
i like those because after you wash it
off you kind of feel like a cold man it
feels so good and it's like so good
that's that's what a clean skin feels
like yeah yeah
the reason i prefer liquid body soap at
least is because just because i feel
like the scents stick for longer like i
feel and smell funny but i do like the
classic dove body soap that [ __ ] you
can't get wrong with that that's great
man that just lathered that stuff on
yeah yeah yeah in the in the uh onsens
in japan there's like no limit to how
many pumps you can do yeah yeah of like
the shampoo and body wash and i mean i
take full advantage of that no normally
it's like you you do one cleaner
in the [ __ ] onsen it's like at least
three yeah i'm like
it'll be like i'd be like how much
conditioner do i want i'm like don't
stop
more
more
i'll do like 10 pumps of conditioner i
won't stop i'm like i want every you
know conditioner sometimes doesn't feel
like it gets in your hair you know yeah
yeah i never use conditioner normally i
don't really feel like it's necessary
yeah but in the in the onsen i'm like
every single like patch of hair that's
left
gets conditioned and the body wash i'm
like
pump
pump another area pump
you literally turn into a [ __ ] yeti
in the end
i'm just like i want to be fully soaked
up yeah
of course man i'm like i'm i'm paying
for it it's just free part of it it's
part of the experience [ __ ] yeah
they just see me like [ __ ] slipping
over because i'm so soapy
[ __ ] i'm trying to get on this
i love it
on the topic of cleaning products at
least there's there's like one thing in
thailand which my mom always buys and i
can't [ __ ] stand it at all and i
don't know why she always buys it like i
feel like with toothpaste it's just
universally known that they should be
like a bit alkali and it's like maybe
minty you know most of the time it's
minty in thailand they sell salt
flavored toothpaste
with like real like with salt cubes in
the toothpaste and why
and it's the most abhorrent piece of
like why
like it's the most thing i've ever
tasted and ever used at all what what
why why would you put something that
dries your mouth out what
i'm so confused
thailand i don't know if it's only
thailand i just know it's like readily
available like [ __ ] everywhere in
thailand and my mom always [ __ ] buys
it who's the measure in the factory like
right so we're gonna make toothpaste and
we're putting chew and put the salt in
what
whoops
toothpaste one of those things where
i firmly believe you have to get a
branded toothpaste every time you know
when you go to hotels and you have their
like toothpaste like tiny white yeah
yeah and it just tastes like you've just
put foam on your teeth you're like i
don't feel like my teeth got clean give
me some aqua fresh or something yeah
yeah yeah i don't know why i i don't
know if this is great branding but i
feel like
it's just one of those products that i'm
like i need to get breakfast no i i'm
the same i definitely need something
more expensive it's i want like a brand
that i know as well though i'm like i've
used that before i've seen that in
commercials yeah that works come some
aqua fresh give me some colgate some
oral b or something yeah oh something
something that feels like it's doing
something yeah yeah because sometimes
especially in the hotel ones they give
you like that that [ __ ] tiny little
white one right the white one right and
like it's meant to last you two brushes
because you do one in the evening and
one in the morning that [ __ ] barely
lasts one yeah why do dentists tell you
to use like a little bit i want to go in
on my teeth yeah right
because you're only supposed to use like
a pee right yeah when i do that i'm like
i didn't do anything do you guys floss
no no
is this an
american thing mainly because because i
don't know a single person in my life
who flosses i think well i'm like it's
something that dentist always tells you
to do but i don't think i've liked it in
the uk don't tell you to floss unless
you ask them should i floss and watch
upon which they'll say yes but they
won't tell you to fall
i'm contractually obliged to say yes
it's like it's not i don't know why
yeah it's one of those things that
america is north america is just
i just can't be [ __ ]
honestly it's a lot of work like i just
want to get in there brush my teeth yeah
it looks clean british in it it's uh
brush your teeth you've got terrible
taste yeah the memes they always do
that's the name they always say when you
tell me don't frost but it's literally
just outside of america doesn't do it i
don't know anyone in europe who flosses
it's not common no you don't really see
it in stores either you have to look for
it it's kind of a specialized item yeah
just on the shelves yeah um but some
people do it i know some people who do
but it's very much of your own
discretion to do it yeah it's not
something that's taught you to do yeah
uh this is like a random tangent
like since we're on like the topic of
sense and onsen and stuff like that how
do i feel how do you guys feel about
massages
because
i don't i don't know if it's cause i'm
thai and when i think massage i think
thai massage i can't [ __ ] stand
massages really yeah you don't like it i
i like
sometimes i'm just like sometimes you
get a massage and i'm just like why did
i pay someone like [ __ ] why did i pay
someone just to beat the [ __ ] out of me
for an hour like
i feel like i'm not old enough to enjoy
them yeah i feel like i haven't i feel
in 10 years time oh really
i feel like i'm still at that age where
i'm just worrying about every single
aspect of the massage when i'm there i'm
like what if they tickle my feet you
know what
what if i'm what if i discover a new
king what if i fart while they're
massaging you know what did you just say
what kind of massage
what if they what if they uh they think
my body's ugly you know all these things
are very uh you know because i had one
where i had to like you know we have to
take off your shirt and stuff i'm like
oh god yes
but you have to right yeah sometimes you
have to be nude right yes i'm in some
massage places i'm just not at that age
where i can appreciate it yeah also to
me it's like i don't know my body isn't
like sore enough
that someone massaging me feels good it
feels good but it doesn't feel like
worth the like hundred bucks you could
be right exactly like i mean i i like i
i hear stories because like and this has
happened to me as well where you go for
massage and like it's so [ __ ] hard
that you just like tears start coming
out and people wear like a badge of
honor like oh man i i went to this room
so much i started crying and i'm just
like
you you paid for this why why why would
you pay someone to like tear your
ligament like that just doesn't make
sense to me but again like i feel you
know when i get to like my 30s and 40s
when you know naturally your body is
going to start to deteriorate it's going
to start to get sore that's i feel the
point where i'll be like [ __ ] i go for a
massage yeah but as of right now it's
like if my body's sore i'll just do a
couple i just feel like
you know when i go to these massage
things i'm like
even though i'm sure they're trained i'm
like i feel like you just
you're just beating the [ __ ] out of that
you're just beating the [ __ ] out of me i
feel like you're not really doing
anything i feel like i feel like you
know i want to question the the training
authority
uh approval today yeah yeah yeah like
like honestly like especially like i
don't know how people can go to massages
for like two three hours
like it's i feel like you need to know
someone who knows the best part because
i've had it in hotels before oh hotels
massages i just thought like this is
just weird i just didn't like this i
felt like i felt like someone called you
up you reluctantly showed up and now
you're just beating the [ __ ] out of me i
feel like you had no appointments
scheduled today
i'm the [ __ ] who scheduled one
appointment today and you came in on
your day off and now you're beating the
[ __ ] out of me for it and you did you
i'm not saying you have to enjoy it i
don't want you to enjoy it but also i
don't want you to [ __ ] hate me
for getting a massage you know i paid
money i don't want to i don't want to
feel like i'm i'm being his stamp what
do you guys feel about saunas i [ __ ]
love saunas bro really i i am a weak
little baby when it comes to saunas my
god like every time every time we go to
an onsen and we sit there like a minute
passes i'm like i'm done because you're
doing everyone does saunas wrong no one
goes in the water before they go in the
sauna do you mean you have to go in the
cold water before you go in i just think
i'm very sensitive or not sensitive i'm
like my
no one enjoys going in the cold water
it's [ __ ] awful no i'm not talking
about cold water i'm talking about heat
right yeah if you go in there after just
going in the onsen when your body's
already at like 37 38 degrees fully
heated up yeah it's gonna be hell go in
the cold water then go in and you'll be
able to do it perfectly no because i i
just feel i just feel like you know
whenever we go to the onsen i'm always
the one who goes into the even the water
the least just because like i i can't
sit or i can't like my tolerance to
being in hot places or like sitting in a
hot place for like a long time it's just
[ __ ] [ __ ] did you go in the cold
watercolor i don't what is that you
should go in the cold water
this is important okay did you go in the
cold water no i didn't there you go
you're honest wait wait you go in the
cold water before you jump in the onset
uh before the sauna sauna i'm supposed
to go in after this one after and then
go back in ah
but like
well like but like sometimes sometimes
you go to nonsense it's just like way
too hot i don't know like that's why i
jump in the cold water
so to me to me that it's to me it's
meant to be a relaxing experience and i
shouldn't need to like
like do a compromise to have a relaxing
experience you know yeah i i don't want
to like you know give myself pain on the
opposite end
i want to be comfortable you know i'm
not paying to give myself an ice bucket
challenge you know you [ __ ] do that
for charity man
uh yeah sorry i was googling so i was
like making i was like i swear there's
like health benefits to uh going in the
uh the cold sauna after especially when
you hit your body up it's like really
has amazing health benefits no no i i
know like saunas have health benefits so
it's like when you get out of that cold
water after going in the sauna as well
god damn does your body feel good oh
yeah i'm sure that's like you know
that's like saying that there's a health
benefit which i'm sure there is to
taking a cold shower in the morning but
i'm pretty sure but i don't want to call
it shut up and i'm pretty sure it's only
like that's like something with that one
in the [ __ ] navy seals next time we
go uh to the onsen please go jump in the
cold water after i swear to god you'll
feel amazing after the sauna after and
before okay i i'll go in i've gone in
after the sauna because that's what
you're supposed to do and it feels
[ __ ] great going before as well
before dude because then you go in the
sauna and it's heating your body up it
feels very nice i just don't even last
long i just don't enjoy saunas because
it's because in japan they suck right in
every time i went in europe it was like
you're in the sauna tm with the boys you
know you you chat and you laugh and you
have a good time in the sauna you you
talk in japan it's like
it's like a lot of talk in the sauna
yeah it's like an interrogation room no
one talks it's just like everyone's just
sitting there and it's like really
awkward and i feel like sauna is where
the camaraderie should come out with you
and the boys she's been skiing you just
been out in the snow whatever i don't
know what the [ __ ] you've been doing but
you talk in the sauna you laugh yeah
that's me that's starting the onsen
though that's that's that's where the
onsen you can do that in the onsen with
less pain yeah yeah but that's how you
get through the sauna as well by talking
with the boys
yeah because if you think about being in
the sauna you can't stay in this one if
you've never been in the sauna uh i i
mean i you can't really relate to this
but yeah yeah it's a very hot ring what
a [ __ ] sauna just a hot room hot room
a really hot room what do you think of
like saunas versus steam rooms i prefer
sauna
what's the difference oh well this one
is like dry
oh right right it's like it's like 90
degrees yeah the steam room is just like
japanese summer
simulator [ __ ] that no it's nice
are way more common but uh steam rooms
are similar but i thought the steam room
sounds horrible that's not that bad
actually but i hate the humidity
well i still get you sweating yeah right
and i i i like nice though when i prefer
steam rooms because it feels like it it
takes longer before
i sweat in the sauna it feels good to
sweat basically that's that's why you're
sitting in the sauna right steam room
just like it it makes that process a bit
faster so i have to stay in there for
shorter a shorter amount of time i just
i just feel like i i get like a re a
relaxing sente relaxing sensation that i
just can't get anywhere else other than
the sauna cold water combo nothing like
it relaxes me have you tried taking a 40
minute [ __ ] that's uh
i thought you guys said like
it's so nice if you're scared of it just
just do one leg in at a time just slowly
get in there
you can't do the one leg at a time
you've got to jump in be careful though
you can go into shock from doing it yeah
right yeah that's what i'm scared of
you just have to that's why you
shouldn't sometimes you shouldn't jump
in it depends on what you are and how
easy you get lightheaded yeah uh i think
i nearly went to shock one time when i
did it geez i jumped in and my heart was
like
and i was like i just like calm down but
oh [ __ ] i spat
like i'd like like calm my body down
cause i felt like i was gonna go into
shock oh it's terrible because your
chest goes super tight if you do it too
fast yeah yeah i mean you're basically
experiencing hypothermia well you're
going you're going from 90 degree room
to 20 degree water yeah that like
submerges your body instantly so you
need to be careful but it is really fun
uh just be careful
it's not a shock but uh yeah it's bad
some of the best things in life are you
know very worrying yeah i mean i mean
it's
that's a quote
i mean like i remember like there's this
uh there's like a [ __ ]
away to onsen i remember us going there
before it closes huh yeah we need we
need to go before we might be close by
the time it comes yeah but like there
are some things which i'm i'm [ __ ]
i'm convinced it's just
we should talk about the onsen actually
before uh we go into the onsen what do
you mean about the 1817 which is being
shut down in japan oh yeah should we
talk about that now so yeah
unfortunately uh away to onsen which is
probably the best onsen in tokyo the
first onsen we went most touristy at
least yeah the first one that jerry took
us to
um is closing down yeah not because it's
not going enough customers not because
of covid uh but because of this
situation
where you can't lease land more than a
certain amount because they were
literally renting the land and yeah it's
expired and it's insane right it's just
an amazing beautiful onsen uh in tokyo
bay right yeah in uh in odaiba like it's
right opposite the [ __ ] gundam as
well yeah literally right next to the
gun so it's it's the perfect day trip
because it's amazing yeah because you go
there you go view the gundam you see a
[ __ ] giant mecca and it's absolutely
incredible and then you just go chill in
an onsen with the boys
this onsen is unlike any other there's
like a whole summer festival area that
is permanently there where you can like
do a bunch of summer activities there's
restaurants in the onsen so once you get
through you can scan it with like this
this uh kind of like watch thing yeah
that's a rubber band yeah you can get
beer you can get a full meal that's
delicious you can get it's amazing
there's so many different baths there's
an outside bath as well there's a sauna
as well yeah and like there's a salt
bath this it's honestly one of the most
amazing onsens it's like a little like
outside garden area yeah
you can spend all day there because have
you like have you talked about like the
middle area where it's just because of
the summer festival yeah the summer
festival where you you do everything
that you've seen in every summer
festival animation you literally you
don't even have to go on the balls yeah
yourself there's like an arcade there
there's there's like good ice cream yeah
the hot milk cold milk yes
you can get beers you can have a full
meal like it was amazing and it's a
shame that it's shutting down because i
don't really know any onsen that's like
like that i'll do it yeah especially in
tokyo is it shutting down this year it's
coming down september yeah oh [ __ ] i
think so uh i want to go one last time i
think by the time this is airing it's
probably gone [ __ ] it's probably gone by
the time this might be close i think it
might be like a week or two yeah yeah
r.i.p but yeah it's an amazing onsen i'm
very sad to see it go yeah
september 5th so what were you saying
sorry yeah so the talking about the
onsen area there so there's this area
we've we've just bigged it up right but
there is this area in an onsen right
um where
it's like it's like a little stream that
you can walk through that's meant to
massage your feet
um
there's massaging your feet and then
there's just walking on pebbles
like being in like one of some of the
most pain in your life yeah and calling
that a relaxing experience yeah what
about that is relaxing i can't i can't
take a single step in that stream yes so
so it's like lots of little like [ __ ]
goblins just [ __ ] doing this on the
bottom of your feet playing every step
and i'm like this is not it's not
relaxing yeah yeah so so so they they
have this little stream right and it's
kind of it's like
people walk on it and it's kind of like
an endurance test right it's not like
you know you know when [ __ ] like
monks like test their endurance by
walking on calls that's what it felt
like because it is very bad because you
have like you have like little pebbles
that are just like soldered into the
ground that just stick out and it's just
like you you're meant to walk on it and
it's meant to massage your feet right
and it it hurts so much
and the
stream goes on forever yeah it's like
it's like 200 meters long yeah it's not
that long but it's pretty long it's
pretty long but then at the end of the
stream there's this little like service
you can do where you can get lots of
little tiny fish to uh oh
yeah this is like the dead skin off your
face this is common in a lot of
countries right so yeah
yeah yeah yeah
as well but it was actually like so i
tried it for the first time with you
guys yeah um and i i still i i think i
still might have the video of us trying
it for the first time if we ever will
play it they're on my legs
i
it's so rare in life that you try
something and you feel a sensation that
you've never felt before in your life
yeah and that was me like feeling like
the hundreds hundreds of little fish
just eating the dead skin it was just
like having hundreds of like mini
electric shocks on your feet yeah and i
remember when i first felt it it felt
like the most uncomfortable thing i'd
ever felt before because i'm just like
what is this sensation i've never felt
this before ever and
then uh
there's a service actually i found in
okinawa the last time i went because
like there was another one in like a
mall in okinawa where you know they had
a little fish so i did it because i
think it feels really [ __ ] nice and
then the guy was like oh there's a if
you go down the road there's a service
where you can get you can do that with
your whole body
uh i don't know you can literally
submerge your entire body all the way up
to your neck and just just stand there
and that fish will just eat your whole
there are certain areas no idea
they weren't doing it but i was like
[ __ ] i kind of want to try
there are certain areas of my body that
i'm just like i don't want fish coming
anywhere near this area man
eating the skin off this one no thank
you thank you yeah
i'm sure like you know maybe we probably
wear pants and stuff like that so that
you know your privates are kind of
covered up but still like i would hope
so could you imagine like a little fish
just like getting like under your arms
and like i'm just thinking like a
[ __ ] nipple man
it's like
probably one of those little protectors
they'll like sneak in through probably
yeah probably
have you guys ever had like a spa day or
like going to like spas
by yourself i haven't gone by myself i
went by myself have you been by yourself
you haven't been by yourself i mean like
i mean sometimes you go to a hotel and
like
sydney just goes for like a spa day and
i'm just like i'm it's you know what i
don't really like spa days because
that's like that's like three hours of
my life that i could be doing relaxing
doing something self-care go on
self-care is it self-care though yeah is
it self-care how much how much more of a
benefit does it do like health-wise
you reckon no no just i mean if it you
know or is it purely just like mental
stress stress is a big killer right so
if you can that's what i mean is it
purely a mental thing well yeah because
it's a mental distress but like having
your body like beaten up or massage it's
not that's not that's not relaxing so
some people it's very relaxing to have
that you know i tried it once actually
when we were staying at a hotel with aki
and now he's like come on just try it
just try it once and i'm like all right
fine i'll try it once i wasn't it was
like a three hour course and i was like
yeah [ __ ] sake that's three hours of
my life gone
and i was like all right you know what
i won't do that again but that was that
was relaxing so low is my blood pressure
until i see the price how much
400 bucks the [ __ ]
the stress comes i don't like doing spa
days well alex came with the deal oh
yeah so i was like oh it's free [ __ ]
yeah i'll do it all right yeah yeah and
i was like that's good but like if i had
to pay 400 bucks for it enough yeah i
could never dedicate more than an hour
to something to doing something that's
meant to be i guess relaxing and i
didn't even experience like two-thirds
of it because i was asleep
i do like i literally woke up i
literally fell asleep while they were
giving me a massage and then two hours
later they were like all right you're
done
and i was like oh good
that was a great experience i did fall
asleep in a massage once actually
i just don't remember anything that
happened clearly you were asleep yeah
you were asleep i felt like i wasted
money because if i fell asleep back up
yeah but like like i mean that's kind of
the point right either you fall asleep
or you get beat in the [ __ ] out and you
feel apparently better afterwards
was it worth it i don't know i don't
really feel more relaxed i just slept in
the middle of the day right you could
have done that in your hotel bed right
honestly honestly that's what i prefer
to do i prefer just browsing my phone
like because the thing the thing about
the spa days is that you're kind of
forced to do nothing yeah wait what do
you want to do on vacation what do you
want to do what's your what's your ideal
vacation i think we've said this before
right but i i just don't want to do
anything i just want to sit in my room i
like that a lot of the time i like you i
want days where i explore but i also
want days where i just sit in the room
and do nothing oh yeah yeah yeah i
appreciate the room's facilities yeah
and just relax my optimal thing is to
just walk around town and just find good
things to eat yeah that's honestly the
best vacation if i don't have a good
meal to look forward to vacation room or
vacation i eat like four meals five
meals a day oh yeah i just turn into
just an absolute glutton yeah like ice
cream after every meal don't mind if i
do
but then my my idea for it is like yes
i'm eating a lot but i'll walk it off
yeah i'm like yes i'm eating a lot and i
like it yeah like like
it's vacation exactly i will like i
remember um in the camping trip that we
went on uh i remember like the first
night so the the first time we went to
uh went camping it was [ __ ]
typhooning yeah right
like we we got there and like we we we
really tried to camp right we were just
like we will we'll we'll [ __ ] a
little bit of rain never hurt anyone
we'll try we get there it's [ __ ]
typhooning it's like it's like a full-on
monsoon the campsite's flooded the tree
is like ninety-nine
degrees and nabi wearing his jeru cam
shirt just goes guys
i don't think we can do it
i've never
i wish it was a special so that we could
film it in the comments be like nah man
just get your [ __ ] axe out and start
putting the tent down
you got it you could have done it mate
you're just little [ __ ] yeah so we
find we find this ryokan uh to go to and
you know it was it was a it was a decent
enough you can you know
complain
and everything um until the point that
we needed to figure out what we were
going to eat and i'm just like cool i'm
on holiday we're gonna we're gonna find
uh we're gonna we're gonna find a
restaurant right guys but unfortunately
we didn't have lunch right so it was
like it was like this
it was like this awkward time period of
if like how you can tell you're raising
in cities only you just didn't have to
worry about where you were eating yeah
yeah because we got there it was like
like an awkward time because none of us
had lunch and it was like like about
three about three o'clock right so it's
too late for lunch but too early for
dinner so we were just like let's get a
little snack that's uh at the combini
right and so we we walk we walk 15
minutes to like the nearest comedy it's
like maybe it was 10 minutes
and we were just like oh let's let's buy
let's buy some drinks and just buy some
snacks
and um and i remember thinking cool this
is just gonna be a quick lunch it's uh
you know we're just gonna get some
snacks and then we'll go to the
restaurant later yeah right and and then
i remember i remember on our way back
right we were just i always just
remember uh the guys had gotten like a
full-on meal and stuff like that and i
was like uh we're going out to the
restaurant again right we're gonna find
a restaurant for dinner right and it was
just that [ __ ] padme meme asking
anakin
when we get back to the hotel and
everyone starts eating and everyone's
like full and i'm just like we're going
out again for dinner right guys
and then it really it finally hit god
when you heard just the crack of the
beer can i open it all right
like i was ready to like it was a great
time with the boys and everything but i
was ready to rate that trip zero out of
ten because i'm just like you guys i
feel like this is vastly someone did not
prepare well this should have been a
conversation that happened like are we
having dinner or not yeah are we doing
it now are we getting complaining this
feels like uh someone [ __ ] up yeah no
no someone definitely you're all [ __ ]
up yeah but you know but then
the moment we it was like you know 1 p.m
like all right now i have to think about
dinner what are we doing i've had a
great [ __ ] camping trip but i won't
forget day one of my holiday i had
combini for dinner conbini food for
dinner on my holiday now we fell asleep
at like 8 p.m
what no correction correction joey fell
asleep at
8pm because i got a [ __ ] face
i had like seven beers in like the span
of an hour and i'm like i'm on a holiday
whatever you're looking for jerry cracks
open the beer and i'm ready for dinner
and joey's [ __ ] i see joey's feet and
i'm just like what the [ __ ] is going
like
joe we're going for dinner ryan jerry's
just [ __ ] having a snooze right there
yeah
i could call me at 11 p.m because
because you and luke yeah because yeah
because aki legitimately thought i'd
died
because i just fell asleep at eight it's
like why is he not responding to my
brother i'm on vacation don't text me
that was a great first day
i don't know about you it was a great
first day had a good talk with the boys
but my god that there's there's that
hole in my life i will never forget but
the problem is as well that like all of
the restaurants were also closed because
it was i think it was a public holiday
when we went so like all the rest so at
like 4 p.m all the restaurants are
closed so we're like well [ __ ] yeah and
well you can't just turn to a restaurant
there's never any restaurants yeah you
had to you've been now we know we're
very lucky now we know for next time to
get a tesco meal deal maybe one day in
advance or you know make your own food
so
i just got to book a book a family mart
camping in like england you should
assume that you make your own food like
you yeah this is a given no we were
going to do that yeah until it started
[ __ ] typhoony
in the comment you gotta do what you can
just start a fire in the car no one's
gonna notice
that's their problem mate you've got
insurance on the car
so don't worry about that it's smoking
if i wanna smoke some meats in my car
i'm smoking some meat especially if it's
a rental car it's not my car i'm
checking it out
all right
p.s don't smoke meat and carve that as a
joke you shouldn't smoke in the car
yeah yeah you showed us
oh [ __ ] why did i do that so there's
something about going out to the uk and
australia right it's it's i think we've
talked about this briefly before
but
it's it's the first time i've ever had a
culture clash or not a culture shock i
should say right it's uh it's always
related to like
whenever you go on a trip with some
people from another country and you got
to decide how much alcohol you're going
to buy
because
for it's it's it's like you get such a
weird spectrum
depending on who you go with yeah you
just never know but for some reason with
it with brits and australian it's always
like a you always have like an agreed
amount that everyone everyone's just
like we should buy more right yeah you
you and the way you do in the uk is what
was a reasonable amount of beers you
would drink in a day yeah and add 50
percent on yeah and then that's your
portion of the beers yeah yeah because
you know maybe someone drinks a lot more
than they expected maybe you drink more
than expected if not you have more for
tomorrow
yeah a beer will never go to waste yeah
yeah so buy more yeah exactly because
like the first time the first time this
ever happened to me when i was just like
shocked right was because like i you
know i understand when you know some
people don't want to drink alcohol
that's completely fine right that's i'm
just like cool but the first time he
actually surprised me was uh i was it
was my first american convention right
and we were gonna hang out at a friend's
place right it was just a group of us
and it was me and one other person
and i was like we should get some beers
for back home and i'm just and he's just
like great good idea i need a beer yeah
right so we go to the fridge right
and i go in and i take out a six pack of
beer as you do right as you do if you're
gonna take some beer back for home of
course then you take a six-pack get some
extra yeah and he he he follows me walks
in
grabs a single can of beer
and then i just i just i just look at
that i just look at him and i just go
what's that he goes it's my drink for
the night i'm just like
are we drinking or are we drinking i i
thought we were going to drink alcohol
and he was like drinking her
yeah he was like yeah we are we're
drinking i was like
how long was i going to last you yeah it
was like oh no this this is my drink for
the night when i say i could go for a
beer i don't mean a single [ __ ] beer
i know i was just like yeah we were
going to go for a beer right yeah who
stops at a single beer
right did i need to be more specific
i could go for a six pack of beer and i
remember the second time this happened
to me was the camping trip actually yeah
you remember when we were we so
in camping you have one opportunity to
buy everything you need for the night
right so that shopping trip you got to
think about the entire state that you're
there right because you're not gonna
have another another opportunity because
we weren't we weren't exactly in the
city yeah and the the shops there are
only open for a set amount that's like
40 minutes away yeah so we're getting
the food and everyone agrees oh do we
have enough food oh maybe we should get
some more food yeah and like we we fill
up this shopping cart full of food right
and then then the alcohol discussion
comes along right and uh
it's uh it's it's uh me joey and luke
who's from northern ireland so you know
we were just like let's go let's get a
crate of beer of course right and how
many people were on the trip again there
were like six of us there were six of us
so like a single crate of beer in my
mind
a single crate of beer to last six
people well how many how many crates how
many beers are in this crate 24 24 okay
okay so it's a 24 pack of beer now a 24
pack of beer to me for six people uh
like
it's not enough beers to last the entire
like day potentially yeah and like the
night if we're counting like we're
probably day drinking exactly
that's like on average four cans of beer
person like that's not gonna last today
at least 330 mils as well
uh yeah like the standard canvas yeah
yeah that's too small
it's too small far too small right and
i'm like like i i i i
have two pints each yeah yeah exactly
exactly that's not gonna be enough i
grab a single pack of like i go out i
grab a uh pack of beer yeah with the
assumption that okay this is where we
start right and i remember i remember i
was gonna put it on the shopping cart
and uh because we we all agreed that we
were going to drink this trip by the way
we it was something that we all agreed
to yeah and i remember i uh i bumped
into eddo right and he sees the pack of
beer and he's like i'll go for a hard
night are we
i'm just like
i don't know what the [ __ ]
this is this is the minimum this is the
minimum this is this is the start this
is the start yeah i remember i remember
going to the shopping cart and i
remember putting the pack of beer on
there and i'm like
so we're getting more now so we're
getting more right guys
it was the [ __ ] padme meme right
again right everyone's like i i don't
know i don't know i remember when he
said that i did like the family guy like
slow head turn off like
you what
at least double that
this is beer
yeah so
so after that i'm just like i take joey
and luke to a corner and we're like it's
like emergency meaning hey guys
emergency meaning i don't think we've
got enough alcohol with us
so like well we kind of don't want to
look like alcoholics like in front of
our mates so let's buy another pack of
beer whatever let's just let's just buy
some spirits
yeah yeah yeah yeah let's get like some
boxes if you're with a crowd or you're
like i don't
want to scare them i'll just get a
spirit yeah the bottle doesn't scare
them when they see like the mountains of
beer cans they're like oh god oh god
it's a hard night yeah yeah yeah
when you you know when in reality it's
probably one bottle of smirnoff or half
yeah
what party animals we are yeah
how long did the 24 crate last year like
three hours
did you run out
well if we didn't buy another one
yeah we ended up buying another very
small yeah
and it was mostly
yeah yeah
i'd say between three people maybe a 24
pack is good enough for a full right
night drinking starting early yeah
eating and talking all night what i've
realized is that how you need to like
decide on like the alcohol amount
whenever you hang out with someone new
it's just like there's an alcohol mount
for brits and aussies and you know
anyone from the uk yeah and then and
then there is just
everyone else with the exception of like
unless there is an exception right i
always bring way more than i need just
because someone's gonna
drink way more than they said they were
going to drink right yeah it always
happens and there's nothing worse than
it being like you know 9 p.m like you're
in front of the fire and then someone
goes hey can i get another beer and
there's no beer yeah because like a lot
of people are worse feeling like like to
me that's just second nature because
like i think i
you need to buy more alcohol than is
needed because nobody like running out
of alcohol when you want to drink more
it's like the word god i sound like also
also i'm just saying this no i sound
like a hurry i agree i guess there's no
worse feeling so you want to be the bro
who provides for the team yeah yeah you
know oh you've run out of beers you
bought your own product i got i got a
few yeah yeah yeah yeah go go grab a
bowl go grab one
don't worry about it and i'm just i've
just kind of realized hanging out with
people from different cultures like
that's the weird part because normally
everyone's everyone keeps asking for
more and then you get to a point you
maybe you run out and some people are
just completely fine with that and i'm
like when i am at like peak tipsy i'm in
the buzz zone i don't know how to run
before i sleep i'm going to sleep like
[ __ ] i i i need this
i need this buzz to keep going man i
need this buzz until i fall asleep
otherwise i'm [ __ ]
i feel like [ __ ] i wake up in the
morning feeling awful help me out man
i'm gonna down a bottle of water or two
before i go to bed i'm gonna feel great
exactly
yeah i mean that's uh
that's the alcoholics anonymous pet
class right wow
i feel
when you're from britain or australia i
think i think i'm going to understand
how ingrained is in the culture and i
feel that further accentuates when
you're on a camping trip oh yeah i don't
know what it is about it i don't know
what it is about sitting around a fire
where you're just like
man i need camping is you know there's a
reason why it's considered one of those
manly activities
and because mentally activities are
normally judged by either how
intensively they are how intensive they
are physically
or how much beer you can drink doing
that yeah fishing is considered a very
manly sport because you can drink beer
the whole time while you're doing it you
know what do you know why i'm gonna say
it how the [ __ ] can you enjoy these
activities if you're not drunk no that's
the thing is it's like is it hanging out
with your friends camping to most people
yeah
hanging out with your friends cooking
[ __ ] food getting drunk very fun yeah
awesome
cooking bacon to a char and then giving
it to your mates and being like bon
apple teeth like that's amazing
why is that
born apple tv it's a sunbrella
it's typically grown apple tea but yeah
burn apple tv
made a genuine mistake no no no
but i actually forget the at the
original because i say the meme one
what is the original bon appetit
i always say the mean one so i can't
bone apple teeth i always say bone apple
tea
you never heard this i've never heard it
it's literally a subreddit where people
like have like uh
it's like spelling mistakes you'll be
like my my autistic guitar or something
yeah acoustic
it's those kind of spiders
it's very funny
burn apple teeth ah but yeah i mean you
you'll eat like terrible food that you
cooked but you cooked it with the boys
yeah like like you think about fishing
as an activity right and on paper right
it's awful
everything that goes wrong could go
wrong you know your hands are getting
slimy when you get the fish maybe you'll
get a fish worst case scenario you sit
there for eight hours and nothing
happens you spend you spent like an hour
setting up the rod because your [ __ ] you
don't know how to fish maybe you're with
the expert he can teach you but you
tangle the the line oh it's a [ __ ]
nightmare everything goes wrong what
bait do i bring i don't know what what
what kind of hook do i bring i don't
know i hate it tying the knot on the
hook is such a pain in the ass yeah god
you've got to get the net out when you
get a fish then [ __ ] when the glorious
big hand comes out that's that's when it
gets good that's what it is that's what
you buy you have to buy the chair that
has the beer holder exactly yeah yeah
yeah yeah see i did that for the camping
trip because i know eventually one of
these days we're gonna go fishing
i'm already prepared
don't pretend that don't pretend like
you planned this i know like okay so for
the camping trip joey brought this
[ __ ] like massive fall-out chair like
not normally like a hundred dollars yeah
yeah jesus christ joe you don't need
that you're not sunbathing yeah i am now
it wasn't one of those ones where you
could like easily fold up and like pack
into a small pack yeah like it was like
[ __ ] rectangular yeah right
like i thought because i thought most of
the the chairs that i've bought that are
like that i thought it was the ones
where you could fold like four ways into
a tube but then when it appeared i was
like why is it only folded in half
and i realized oh it's because there's
two giant metal rods
that are like keeping the entire thing
together that just won't bend yeah and i
lifted it up and i'm like why does this
thing weigh 20 kilograms
it was like it was something like the
greek god of this capture bring me
another grape honestly honestly honestly
the chair itself was like king [ __ ] it
was it was like it was like a [ __ ] it
wasn't every time i got up to like go
get wood or go to the toilet someone was
always like
i'm sitting in the king's chair
honestly
it wasn't a camping chair it was a
[ __ ] throne
right well like don't pretend like you
did that you did that by complete
accident because i did it you know what
it was it was a [ __ ] [ __ ] to get in
the car because we were going camping
and the car was like the car
it barely fit in the boot yeah it was
barely fitting it was it was heavier
than my bag full of all of my clothes
and [ __ ] it's a seven-seater and the
chair took like two seats
exactly
you took one seat and took away two
exactly fantastic i mean joe had a great
time sitting down at the end of us
driving there and having like less space
oh yeah to like sit but what was it
worth it it was this one
what the [ __ ] is that it has like a
foldable like uh table on the side and
it was like a [ __ ] colonial
imperialist master oh yeah yeah going to
your new land i was like some game of
thrones [ __ ] dude like god i thought i
felt so powerful
oh man but yeah like like for you like
fishing i don't know how you can enjoy
without alcohol because most of it is
just
nothing you're just sitting there yeah
you're just waiting
doing you bring the nintendo ds or you
just get drunk and talk there's only
options now i guess yeah other nintendo
that's
two
ds just play some smash bros while
you're waiting for the field trip i mean
that's what you can do man you dig that
pole in the ground and start drinking
exactly until you think you've caught a
fish and you're too drunk to
realize uh we still need to go fishing
yeah well yeah i'd like to go camping
and do it properly but it seems like in
japan there's not many good camping
sites they all seem very
they're very controlled very close
together and
it just seems like a shitty nightmare
would you rather go fishing like off the
bank or would you rather be in a boat
uh probably off the bank and just
sitting in the chair off the bank yeah
in the boat you you should be very
active when you're doing i don't know
i prefer the boat i don't know you're
gonna be in a rowboat though not like a
big boat oh okay no i'm not like a yacht
okay i'm gonna be in a room like a rocky
[ __ ]
why the [ __ ] would i want to be in that
bro simulating i'm a i'm like a broke
fisherman in god's head boat equals
yes i want to be on the louis vuitton
ss3
the louis vuitton ss3 that's the name of
the
name of my boat that's the name of the
bot though
yeah i don't want to be in a robo and i
don't think connor wants to be on a
robot with me either because uh he'll
he'll [ __ ] find a way to tip it gone
will [ __ ] tip the boat i mean we've
been on a robo together i remember when
we went to kyoto and yeah
i just can't roll for [ __ ] yeah and then
also just turns into like daddy long
legs in this [ __ ] way he can't just
stand up properly and he was like having
great difficulties he's going to hit the
boat he's going to tip the boat any
second now
i wanted to see that yeah he stood up
and he was just like whoa
oh my god please god god please please
yeah he was terrible at rowing
yeah i don't know i don't i didn't know
what i was doing wrong i don't know i
think he just kept putting it in and
then just pulling it out you didn't just
like row i don't know
i'm just kind of like you know i feel i
feel like i'm like you know i quagmire
or something where where you have he has
like once one arm stronger after he's
like
yeah yeah literally i just keep going
around
circle what are you doing
in both pulling both we know which one
god's fapping armies
oh my god rowing boat sucks though
really i enjoy it
not not when the conditions that we were
doing yeah we were we were doing it in a
japanese summer oh
my time i left my back was like that my
shirt was a different color yeah that's
not cool the fall is really really nice
i was doing manual labor in the summer
i don't even do manual labor normally
let alone in the summer and we were
hungover as well
i probably hate it too
honestly doing anything outside in
japanese summers is just like nope nope
let's let's just let's just do an indoor
activity the weekly reminder the
japanese summer sucks we're gonna keep
complaining about it until it's over
yeah all right yeah i love winter winter
yeah i don't know man i just i just
don't understand people who who just
like this heat and this humidity
psychopaths man talk about this i get it
man
i mean god i felt so bad for the [ __ ]
olympians right like we talked about
this but jesus christ was terrible yeah
yeah changing the topic though like no
i've i feel like i've lived in japan for
long enough now that my opinions on
certain things have changed some things
which started which i initially thought
were amazing
are now
like i i i don't think are as good as
like bridges okay
eg
wagyu beef
okay remember the first time i tried
wagyu beef it's so over praised yeah i'm
just like oh my god this is the [ __ ]
short choice of beef it's a it's the
[ __ ] ferrari of beef and then you
live here for a year and you have equal
you you have easy access to it and i'm
just like i just kind of want a normal
ribeye now i just kind of want a normal
steak genuinely normal steak
is better because wagyu is just fatty
and if you like that you like that but
if you want like a really nice tender
cut of meat it's just so good michael is
good maybe like you know once or twice a
year i think like if you really want to
like treat me if chris was here he'd be
he'd be like no no no i know the best
places
he's going to the wrong places when i
went to kyoto right with chris
there was this stand and we were kind of
hungry and the stan said there was wagyu
beef on a stick
for like a thousand yen yeah yeah i was
like no way is that wagyu yeah no
[ __ ] way and they had this meat out
on the counter like this example me and
i was like all right fine we'll get it
we'll try it we'll try it
and so they have this example meat of
what the meat looks like yeah and uh
it's like the fake kind um and so we
order it we pay the man and uh he pulls
out some meat from a cooler that is
definitely not wagyu it's literally like
the shittest cut of a beef you can
imagine right right literally impossible
to chew a dog would have trouble chewing
this thing right yeah and i was like
chris
a couple of you thought this was gonna
be real there's no way we would get
steak on a stick for 1 000 yen outside
of the for the [ __ ] uh
whatever it was oh yeah yeah yeah like
at a tourist trap are you serious chris
i couldn't believe that he fell for it
and then he convinced me to actually try
it what a waste without we took like two
bites and we're like we can't eat this
this is [ __ ] we threw it away yeah
i mean because like i feel i had the
better experience because like when on
journey across japan we had that exact
same thing in takamatsu and it was the
hiragyu beef which is like it's like a
higher brand
that one was actually delicious because
you're not in kyoto which is yeah yeah
basically it's turned into kind of
shadows
it's kind of you can get some good stuff
there but it's so over tourist uh so uh
i don't know you gotta you gotta go with
tourists you
yeah because because i feel like wagyu
beef is
something that you should try as like uh
as like a a rare thing right because
what i didn't expect was how easy it
would be to access it you can buy it in
the [ __ ] supermarket oh yeah
like like it's it [ __ ] blew my mind
the first time i saw wagyu beef in the
supermarket where the only other time
i'd ever seen wagyu beef is like at like
[ __ ] high-end
high-end restaurants where you'd be
paying hundreds and hundreds of dollars
for a few keys of wagyu beef yeah and i
remember before coming to japan i'd only
tried it once and that was because i was
like i had like a well-off friend who
treated treated us to uh treated us
dinner once at a high-end restaurant and
i'm just like oh my god this is [ __ ]
incredible and i now i understand why
they only give you a few cubes of wagyu
beef in like highest right it's way too
it's like eating pure butter yeah right
and i realized this when i'm just like i
i think it was like
i think it like hacked my mind to be
like okay wagyu beef is always good it's
i'm i can't get bored of wagyu beef this
is this is the this is a5 beef right but
now i i see waggy beef and i'm just like
can i just get a normal cut of steak
please the thing is that the normal cuts
of steaky just aren't that good yeah
they're not they're not you know unless
you pay like a good amount for it right
yeah yeah and the best steaks here are
like a lot of those you get some really
good steaks but a lot of them are
imported yeah and they're really
expensive yeah yeah you know you're
paying an absolute premium
and again like it's like i feel wagyu
beef is a lot like you know getting like
the super fatty tuna like sushi it's
like you can't eat that [ __ ] all the
time it's it's because you eat it every
now and then right that is good i think
i don't know how i don't know if japan
did this intentionally or not but it's
definitely a branding thing yeah like
wagyu beef is
very good branding yeah uh i don't know
how because it's all over the [ __ ]
place in japan you don't know what's wag
you what can what's constituted as wagyu
it's like it's not it's like well that's
the thing right every prefecture has its
own wagyu and they'll argue that the
other one is [ __ ] and there's the best
well that's the thing i feel that's the
biggest misconception with wagyu is that
people when people think wagyu beef they
think like a5
yeah
the best [ __ ] right but like wagyu beef
literally just means beef made in japan
yeah yeah there's like there's like low
tea wagyu as well as high tier why do
you yeah i don't know how i don't know
who if japan did this on purpose i don't
know if like
it honestly might change honestly it
might be the foreign chefs though though
it could have been foreign
when did it become a thing when did
wagyu become like well-known
in like outside of japan and become like
this kind of idolized beef yeah because
i feel like that's how wagyu is
commands such high prices especially
outside of japan yeah it's because of
the branding like yeah it is you know
it's the same with you know i don't
think you know when you eat uh what's
the [ __ ] uh what's the
um really fatty uh meat cold that you
get
uh
foie gras foie gras foie gras
i don't think it is
do not i think that's right how
i don't know how the [ __ ] they've
managed to charge that's so much fun
that is also just eating pure fat i i
just i eat it i'm like [ __ ] i i feel i
feel like i feel i feel like a bit sick
sometimes because i was like it's very
fatty yeah it is very very funny and
kind of wagyu kind of feels the same off
how do they convince us that foie gras
was like a luxury item and that we
should pay out of our pockets insane
amounts for it i wouldn't barely take it
it's a [ __ ] trick to make that's why
you say that but then like you know uh
we we like killed caviar to the point
where we made them so extinct that we
made them valuable yeah like
caviar was never going to be valuable
again like the only value of caviar
comes from the fact that it's so rare
like well it's similar with lobsters
right right we've made it yeah we've
made it like lobsters
lobsters used to be the cheap me that
you know they right they uh that the
working class people used to right and
then i'm not sure why it increased in
price i don't i don't know if like the
corporations
like
uh because the working class
artificially it's been overfished yeah
it was was it over officials they
artificially believe it's been
overfished
but it's a really interesting story and
i wish i could remember the detail of it
but like i know i all i know is like
lobsters was a really cheap meat until
one day it just wasn't there
right and then it was like just to show
though the price you know doesn't really
correlate with good tasting food i mean
you know like i hate to shadow whales
all the time but you know there was some
really fresh local produce that was so
cheap yeah you know and that was amazing
and i still haven't had better stuff
anywhere else from like you know from
from there yeah and and you know i don't
want fog i just want a nice beautiful
cut of meat fresh from the day yeah and
it's yeah like wagyu beef i feel like
when i first moved to japan i could not
understand why every steak like they
marketed it as like imported from
australia and i'm just like why would
you import beef when you have wagyu here
and like now living here for like like
almost two years i'm like i get it i
want a [ __ ] australian steaks
beef's a [ __ ] dog
it's like a very luxury thing like
there's a lot of they import a lot of
beef from like ireland and stuff too
here yeah yeah yeah ireland exports a
lot of meat to japan yeah because like
if if you're bored of wagyu beef then
just the normal cuts of beef here just
aren't as good as uh yeah and like you
can play around a lot more with the
seasonings yeah yeah on the normal i
feel with a lot of those kinds of foods
like wagyu and like foie gras and stuff
like that it's all just like a namesake
right it's it's just like you know i
don't think anyone realistically [ __ ]
everything there's probably somebody
every week is like oh where's my four
grocer like you know it's it's like
puffer fish right like fugu is also
another thing where it's like you eat it
just to say you ate it yeah yeah like no
one is like actually gonna be like oh
fugu is the best tasting thing of all
spoilers it's not it literally tastes
like nothing
i've had it a couple of times and i'm
just like yeah just put your life in
danger yeah i'm like and i'm like this
is cool i guess i can say that i ate
puffer fish but it's like man sometimes
i just wish i was like a [ __ ] dog bro
you can give them the same meal every
single day and they get hyped as [ __ ]
for it yeah all right is it time for the
same meal again yo you got to be kidding
me pesco
spoiling me they get so high for the
same meal every time meanwhile i have
the same meal twice in a row and i'm
like i'm living like a peasant
i had gary two days in a row
i don't know is this like a thing that
we we did to ourselves as humans was
there once a point in time where we were
just happy to have the same meal over
and over again oh yeah i'm sure
why have we done this we probably we
probably were even as a kid right i
remember when i could just eat thai food
every day oh yeah you'll never get never
get bored of the potatoes again oh you
got to be here
man let's go
put some salt on there oh yeah let's go
change it up a bit with some beans and
that [ __ ] let's go and then like i tried
i tried like japanese food for the first
time i'm just like damn i want to try
this again i tried mexican food for the
first time i'm like [ __ ] giving you
my
my need of variation and uh taste has
skyrocketed since japan like it spoiled
me because now i used to be content just
eating like fried chicken like four
times a week and i would be like this is
fantastic that's the second thing i
think is overrated in japan
yeah well japanese don't really i don't
think they do fire chicken very good
here no no i think i think
like americans think they like have
mustard fried chicken and i'm like no
the best fried chicken i've had is from
korea korean fried chicken best in the
world yeah i said it they season it they
don't go too overboard in america you
get way too much seasoning yeah yeah in
korea you just get like beautiful
different variations of seasoning the
yum yum chicken is like and it's not
just that it's just so good it's the
perfect texture as well where it's just
like a little bit crispy yeah it's it's
it's you can't like it's the perfect
it's the perfect a little bit crispy and
like the meat's not too wet but yeah
it's not dry
it's just the perfect combination of
everything you'd want in a fried chicken
but also not to dog on like
fried chicken culture in london is
amazing we have such good fried chicken
in london
really disagree that's what we have
that's right
that's why we have a whole channel
that's why there was a there was a whole
channel at one point dedicated to
reviewing fried chicken in london it's
so very [ __ ] way too greasy man no
you're going to the wrong plate you're
going wrong
you're going to the wrong block you
sound like chris right now
he's going to the wrong places no
because london is so varied in the
church we were so close to having a
podcast where we agree on everything
no i know
that's amazing man fried chicken in
london it's only amazing after you're
[ __ ] shit-faced
it's like people who defend kebabs and
i'm just like would you ever use music
about sober no no you probably haven't
there's a reason you're [ __ ] you
probably had a [ __ ] local fried chicken
shop the one underneath me was amazing
the the way they seasoned the chicken
[ __ ] they did barbecue wings and i have
never had barbecue wings as good as this
in my life they they were so cheap too i
don't know what they put in it probably
likes all god-awful chemicals yeah but
that [ __ ] was amazing i've never had
barbecue wings that are as good as that
and it was like it was like one pound
for like eight warring it waringly cheap
i thought it was amazing i thought that
was cheating
probably even wasn't i don't know what
it was but it was the best wings i'd had
jeez i mean like to me the best fried
chicken i've had in the uk is kfc like
this okay okay it's i'm not gonna say
it's the best because that's saying but
it is very good in the in the uk it is
some reason they make very good kfc it
is very good and like every fried
chicken i've had in london or every
chippy or whatever it's it feels like uh
it feels like a downgrade to kfc to me i
feel like you guys do chicken pretty
well though can you see in the uk is by
far the best kfc i've ever had in japan
it sucks yeah oh no japanese stuff in
america it's war crimes yeah elsewhere i
assume it's just not as good as
australia it's a little bit over i'm
sure there's someone from some country
that's like yeah but in in this country
it's better should i i haven't i haven't
been there so how would i know that yeah
we don't we don't try kfc in every
country we go to unfortunately boneless
or bone
bone boneless boneless fat i'm a
boneless kind of guy man i'm a boneless
get that get that bone out of there if i
can't eat it get it out of my face
sometimes i just don't want to go
through
if i gave you two plates one of them
came from a bone chicken one of them
came from boneless chicken you would not
be able to tell a [ __ ] difference
guaranteed
i would i would guarantee you you will
not be able to make more right now the
moisture the moisture is there it's it's
more
natural flavor of the chicken
it tastes the best
the texture is better as well
everything is better
the other ones get the veiniest
[ __ ]
steroids into these chickens the only
thing that is that is a detriment is the
fact that is a bone chicken but that's a
i will happily pay the price for a
better tasting chicken okay it's just
okay and then like when you get to the
ends this [ __ ] does not want to come off
the bone you have to like be like a
feral animal to get this thing off the
[ __ ] boat it's just time to break my
teeth
it is worth it for the better taste okay
no it's not because you can eat more way
more chicken you know because boneless
chicken is just chicken breast yeah
yeah it's amazing it's no it's not it's
not always chicken breast prone
the chicken
is yeah it is always chicken breast and
the meat tastes the same on the wings
you know what you're not the breast you
know i i don't think the breast is the
best part of the chicken i think it is i
think it is you know what i like i like
moisture with my meat and you can get a
moist expressed the breast is you can
get a moisturizer are you kidding me you
can get a moisturizer you can get the
moist breast right
like
a lot of the times you [ __ ] you cook
a chicken breast and it can yeah you
you're cooking it you're cooking
my man's never did a bad job on the
chicken man it was always fresh like
like like sauce contained like i've had
enough chicken breasts and random chips
and random places well just the breast
is too dry you can never get under the
wrong chippy no you can never get in
london i would never get a boneless
chicken they don't do boneless chicken
well enough outside that's what i'm
saying right because because you need to
cook chicken breast right in order for
it to be
korean places here and they have
boneless and and boned always boneless
peppers are always because this [ __ ] is
just better you also get more of it
because they don't they don't try and
[ __ ] stack go to nando's what'd you
get what did you get
uh i got like half a chicken yeah why
why don't you get the uh boneless uh the
the boneless the boneless one
when you go to nando's ah they don't do
the boneless juice yes they do i don't
even know they did that i would have got
the bomb now he knows so he's going to
get the ball no no actually i joke i
don't get the half chicken i get the
butterfly burger which has no bones
because i don't want to deal with bones
that is definitely drier than the half
cheese that's why you pile on the sauce
baby oh
it's totally up to the chef man and how
he cooks it for personally you don't
need to play you don't need to pay that
gamble if you just get the half a
chicken off the bone because you know
what it's always juicy oh it's good it's
good but i don't the butterfly chicken
burger is just fine as well this is the
same thing and then you can just sauce
it up it could be better it could be
better it's just i just think i think
the nando's chicken is comfort food it's
not the best but yeah i don't i didn't
expect five-star [ __ ] burn chicken
fried chicken is right it's kung fu food
i've had you know i've been to michelin
star restaurants and i've had times
where i just want the fried chicken more
like it's just so much better to me i
love a good fried chicken but it's done
right this man literally goes
but i feel like there's a very american
side of me
look there's there's a reason why soup
is made from the bones of animals right
and that's because the bones contain
flavor you're not eating if i wanted to
eat soup i'll eat soup if you're not
eating the [ __ ] bone marrow god you
know i'm cracking the butt you're like i
don't go to the restaurant with you like
honey you gonna eat your bones i'm gonna
eat that bone marrow bro cracks it open
you know like you're not the in the
you're not in the bone the bone doesn't
do it this bone bone does do [ __ ] it
does oh my [ __ ] god i'm sure it does
at a fast food restaurant it doesn't do
[ __ ] i'm sure it does with the bone on
it i'm sure it does if they marinate
[ __ ] with the bone in yes the bone will
have an effect
but when you're at fast food they
literally got that chicken in the van 20
minutes ago and it's on your plate
there's no time to have the bone plain
effect
you're just getting boned
that was god that was that was a raise
i rest my case i'm sure it does make
your difference but i'm not it does i'm
not even going to do that it's not an
argument it makes i am not even going to
pretend to start
i'm going to start to pretend that i
think i know the [ __ ] difference
i don't do you have taste buds joey yeah
do you have taste buds
you can tell the difference and you do
have a tongue you know what i taste
man who doesn't like sauce i don't
[ __ ] trust a goddamn thing i have
taste buds and you know what i taste
[ __ ] chicken i don't give a [ __ ] if
it's from the bone or not from the ball
oh yeah it tastes like chicken all
chicken tastes the same joey all meat
stays the same it's just beef it tastes
the same it comes from the same animal
all beef tastes the same every cut of
beef is the same all chickens taste the
same no it doesn't all chicken taste the
same most parts of the chicken in terms
of like this the skin and the you know
because the wing is just an extension of
the breast in terms of how the meat is
it's
me the meat i'm about to find
i didn't say that
i don't take responsibility for that
statement the ring the wing the meat
part of it tastes exactly the same
that's why they can make boneless wings
and call it wings it doesn't taste any
different the only problem is with the
bone is you get like veins and [ __ ] and
then it's like i don't want that who
wants the vein who's like what the [ __ ]
is boneless wings
the boneless swings right there you go
to buffalo wild wings you get any of
those places all it is is just chicken
breast cut up
did you know that to make it look like a
wing yeah to me because like i've never
gotten boneless wings because i'm like
what the [ __ ] so you've known this week
so you've never tried it mm-hmm so
you've never tried it i've tried
boneless chicken well you said you never
ordered it i've never tried boneless
wings but i've had like a boneless chick
it isn't all chicken boneless when you
get it like a restaurant
no
you get wings no no when you get wings
yeah yeah yeah but when you get wings
boneless swings every time no no you got
it you gotta it's off the bone chicken
is always taste better off the boat it's
less healthy for you the only reason why
people promote breast is because it's
the leanest meat right that doesn't
necessarily mean
the winged meat like the actual meat
that you're eating tastes no different
from the breast
it's the moisture content and it's it's
you it's the bone flavor that seeps into
the chicken sometimes it just it tastes
better unless we're at a gourmet
restaurant i would i would say that's
invalid because you know these these
fast food restaurants you know and the
the place where you're eating wings from
90 percent of the time isn't going to
have the bone play any effect i'm not
gonna go to buffalo while we see a
boneless chicken go what the [ __ ] is
this
okay you have a kfc bargain bucket or
your kfc [ __ ]
do you have preferences of which one
which piece you take because every piece
tastes different
and if and and if
every piece of kfc chicken tastes
different depending on the part of the
chicken
the only difference is that you get a
different ratio of skin
surface skin to like meat yeah and with
the with the wings
with us the drumstick you're the optimal
skin to meet ratio yeah i can't right so
you get more skin yeah so it tastes
better whereas the big the big like flat
piece what i don't know what it's called
what's it called the big flat piece
what is
there's two pieces there's the wing and
then there's the other piece oh like
that like the one that seemed like that
it's kind of like a big piece like this
you could get more meat yeah so you
don't have as much taste worse the the
worst the whole there's less skin yeah
no it tastes worse because it's just
purely in meat right
i don't want it
on it i don't want fat i taste any no
you're confusing it because you're
having more skin which is where all the
flavor is with kfc that's why you think
it tastes better because you're getting
more bite of a skin
how are you not seeing this how are you
failing to understand this gone i i
literally don't give a [ __ ] when it
comes to kfc it's it's
talking about friendship it's all
[ __ ] chicken to me oh my [ __ ] bone
or no bone the best
i love boneless wings i love fried
chicken burgers yeah i love uh the like
chicken select so whether chicken
tendies
are [ __ ] amazing chicken tennis are
better than dogs down and and wings with
bones in them
the part of the chicken that nobody else
eats right but they've repackaged it
but like do you know why it's the worst
tasting part of the chicken boneless
boneless is better than bones
you are so wrong on something you know
what i'm not i'm not man i'm just trying
i didn't think freedom of speech was a
mistake until i hurt until i just heard
you speaking bro you're a clown man like
why are you making it more difficult to
eat this and you're making more mess
you're the reason flat earth has existed
no i'm not like this is this is like
is it isn't boneless just like nuggets
no no no no no no boneless system
you're not in this conversation boneless
nuggets nuggets are like chicken extract
it's hardly a chicken it's paste you
know yeah it's like uh it's like
polystyrene with chicken tasting
you know and chicken tenders are good
chicken tenders chicken tenders are
awesome
i think we're all in agreement chicken
tenders are good yeah we're gonna agree
with you yeah i mean off the bone
chicken is always the best um that's
that that is yeah when it's taken off
the boat yeah we're taking it off the
boat off the bone and then fried and
then presented kind of like
kind of like no no no no no no no no no
no no
[Music]
no because because you're taking the the
most tastiest part of the book
chicken off the bone is literally
boneless chicken with one extra step
[ __ ] the best is the worst tasting
part of the chicken it is
have you tasted chicken [ __ ] it's the
most healthiest
huh have you had chicken feet okay well
that's okay
yeah yeah yeah yeah backtrack okay okay
it's the most it's the worst tasting
part of the chicken that's like actually
you know
it's got meat white meat yeah it's got
meat on it right technically it's it's
the most healthiest for you you know
it's it's you know if you want to eat a
healthy meal you should eat the leanest
part of the chicken which that doesn't
necessarily mean it tastes the best and
the fact that you think that all chicken
tastes the same no matter what part of
the chicken is from you are so wrong the
meat part of it like the breast the wing
it's all come to know how it's prepared
it doesn't you know it's entirely to do
with that and how much water has been
injected into it and like
if if you if you prepare each part of
the chicken the same which is exactly
what fried chicken is then the worst
pacing uh then but it tastes the same
then it doesn't taste toasty
i guarantee i can take two different
fried chicken from two different parts
put it in front of you blindfold you you
would not be able to hold it i would
because [ __ ] breasts especially in
fried chicken it's not moist at all it's
dry a lot of the time i think you're
just you know you're confusing the feral
instinct of tearing it off as a as a
supplement for flavor i think i think
that's what's going on here because
there's no way you know when you rip the
skin off and you would eat it it tastes
the same why don't they just sell
breasts then why why because chicken
tastes the same they do it's called
boneless wings yeah
no i mean i mean why why why market
wings in that case because people are
like you why would you think they know
the difference by market thighs because
what do you mean thighs because thighs
are like uh what are they i mean like
more cartilage they're cheaper right
like they're normally just like they
have more like [ __ ] in them more muscle
and stuff what the cartilage you have
chicken it's like muscle i'm not talking
about color i'm talking about thighs you
said something thighs and cartilage i
just said oh yeah thighs have more like
cartilage in them though like i'm like
and like [ __ ] muscles and spiders are
you talking it's just me it's it's a
different part of the meat that tastes a
bit different to the breast no the
thighs have more muscle in them it's a
thigh what the the breast has more
muscle in it it's we literally talked
about this the breast is the lean part
of the chicken that's the part with the
most muscle no
i'm just going to hang back
you know when you bite into a meat right
when you've bought thigh there's just
loads of like fibers and [ __ ] that
you've got like
oh [ __ ] you know what i mean
no what i really don't what when you go
to the supermarket and you cut up
chicken thigh you can put a chicken
breast the breast is like nothing in it
you're a female cook it's your pure meat
right the thigh it's just like it's got
like like [ __ ] strands of muscle in
it and [ __ ] and it's way tougher yes
it's because it's a thigh it's got
[ __ ] muscle
i don't think i don't think we've ever
been this silent have you ever cooked a
chicken thigh and a chicken breast you
know i'm like i can't argue that you
know why like if you argue with an idiot
they'll just take you down to their
level and beat you with experience man
how can i argue how do you argue with
you you're just like wrong on so many
[ __ ] levels
like a thigh doesn't have the most
amount of muscle because it's it's not
the lean meat right it's the breast the
breast is pure muscle it's pure muscle
what do you think or like all the meat
is muscle right but the breast the
reason the breast has the most muscle is
because it doesn't come with the bone
you have just you have a pure slab of
pure chicken muscle
what are you saying oh my god
the breast isn't just one big muscle
what do you think meat is
what do you think meat is it's a layer
of different things there's like fatty
layers and stuff as well it's a whole
combination thing such as all just pure
muscle yes it is no it is no no because
it's like fibers and stuff that connects
all the muscle
that's a muscle
i gotta google this i gotta consult
google
i'm like losing my mindset
i'm actually losing my mind
breasts can take like like it consists
of like fat
yeah it's this this is just turned into
iris which is a part of the which is a
muscle
yeah
are you are you all entertained i am
i'm not i'm i'm loving i'm just sitting
back just watching you guys lose it over
literal pieces of chicken i'm losing
brain cells man like that's like uh i
don't know how many brain cells has just
died in this case
i can't believe you're getting heated
over poultry
okay it's just hilarious i i
misunderstood what i was saying i've
googled it
i i misunderstood tendons and like
muscles and i confused the two
it's all right man it's all right to
admit when you're wrong it's all good
it's all good i'm wrong you know what
you're the bigger man you're the bigger
man don't worry man i'll admit when i'm
wrong i [ __ ] up i [ __ ] up
thank you you know this episode started
really you know this episode started
really calmly talking about candles
incense you know de-stressing and and
it does taste worse it ends up being one
of the most stress inducing
why couldn't we have started on this it
ended on the massage
because the muscle is used more often
than the breast it not only became the
most stress inducing argument but also
at the same time i think it became
i'm googling it again i think it became
one of the most stupid arguments we've
ever had on trash taste the reason the
breast meat is the most lean is because
that's the muscle that's the most used
no it's the least used
audio only listeners you might want to
watch tune into the youtube version of
this to see
two men melting down over poultry i'm
just like only on trash taste
you know what i didn't think we could
get more heated than the pizza crust
argument yeah but like
so i'm just i'm just i'm just like
i'm just
like i i just i would i just love like
peering over
the thigh is considered a darker meat
because it's used way more when because
they're walking all the [ __ ] time
they're not [ __ ] using their breasts
all the time so what's lean meat then
lean meat i think it's when it's used
less
is it i
think compared to other parts of the
meat
i thought that was because it was used
the most so here's what google says
apparently uh i googled why is thigh
dark meat and it says uh the more
myoglobin the darker the meat and the
richer the nutrients myoglobin provides
muscle with oxygen required for exercise
and movement since chickens are flatless
birds they use their legs and thighs to
get around making those thoughts darker
than the breasts or wings because you're
not you're using how would you how how
would you think that the breast is used
more than the thigh how does that make
any sense to use your breasts more than
your thigh gone think
i was wrong on the muscle part yes but
how could you think that the breast is
used more than that
i i
the playing field but you're still wrong
you're still [ __ ] wrong
we're both [ __ ] idiots and welcome to
trash taste welcome to trash talk
welcome to trash test two idiots arguing
over chicken
i feel like i feel like 30 minutes
wasn't enough
i just want to know how you thought the
chicken walked in your mind
[Music]
i just want to know how you thought the
breasts had less muscle we all actually
i just did a brain fog that's my excuse
we all know we all know chickens shimmy
when they walk right
i just they just hear the
[ __ ] like uh the samba music
oh my god
yeah
i mean i just i just thought lean meat
just had uh more muscle use that's what
i thought i thought when i hear the word
lean meat it means it's got less fatty
content so i just i mean someone's lean
right they have some muscles but not
that much right you kind of have like no
it's not worked out me right it's kind
of like
not fat meat but not
very skinny or like that like i think
right am i crazy
you say someone's lean when they look
like
skinny and they look skinny but they're
clever
yeah they've got a little bit going on
yeah yeah i mean yeah because there's
only the muscle content they're like
they're not muscular though
fat there's no fat content yeah yeah
there's no fat content yeah right right
you got lean yeah so so i assumed that
because it was lean meat then it would
have less fat content therefore it was
the one that was used the most right
that's what that's because that's my
like yeah i guess by that logic it'd be
like if i didn't do anything and didn't
and didn't have any fat i would be
muscular that's right but i'm not using
my muscles because
i'm still like confused because the more
you use a muscle the more the more like
muscular it becomes the more nutrients
it demands so how does the breast have
the most meat and muscle in it then so
so when you're working out right the
muscle fibers become a lot more like
intense and i believe they go through
like they're in the the meat a lot more
right i think if i'm correct in saying
that yeah the the that's because that's
what makes like when you when you go to
space right your muscles get [ __ ] the
muscle fibers are so weak because they
haven't been used so when they i believe
when they're being used they're a lot
more intense that's why when you have
the thigh it's it bites back a lot more
it's tougher to eat because the the
muscle fibers are so much stronger
that's what i how i interpreted it right
right
again i i misunderstood and that's why
lean meat because the breast isn't you
know you're really using the breast much
so there's not much muscle fiber to
plant there yeah yeah just
i don't even know where to take this
conversation anymore i'm just like
i'm just like i i don't think this
episode can peak any more then yeah i
feel feel like i'm just gonna go
downhill yeah we're just gonna go
downhill from here so you know what
let's just [ __ ] show the patrons this
might be a shorter episode than usual
but uh i i i i don't i feel like any
other topic we can take from this is
gonna it's gonna be going let's let's
just end while we're high yeah let's
just say while we're at the high just
joey had a fun spectrum
i was literally that you know that meme
of like the two guys
yeah i was just like sunday afternoon
over here watching yeah just like i just
like how we had such a civil podcast
yeah we're having such a simple podcast
and i literally remember the moment when
it was just like i didn't say it on
purpose but i just said i
disagreed
i didn't do that on purpose i know
that's the mean by it yeah he seriously
didn't do that conversation is like
modern day times when things get too
peaceful war is bound to come exactly
exactly we went from aromatherapy to two
men it was
veins popping out on their forehead
overnight oh you think candles are good
well that's how world war one started
all right well then here's all the
patrons hey let us know in the comments
which part of the chicken you prefer i'm
sure that won't turn into a famous gang
boneless countless gang no no not all
chickens taste the same all the chicken
tastes like something chicken tastes
better we're gonna do something that
we've never done before and i'm doing
this without asking information we're
going to do a poll on twitter the day
after this goes up you guys have one day
to vote on boneless or bone yeah
but uh hey in the meantime you can go
over to our patreon patreon.com trash
taste also follow us on twitter uh send
us your memes on the subreddit and if
you hate our face listen to us on
spotify although this episode might not
be too great for spotify this we
recommend the youtube version for this
to watch two minutes
don't tell them
yeah i i i don't know how much i peaked
the mic i really hope it wasn't too bad
but like the mics are built differently
yeah don't worry about it it's all right
that's it i love how we went from
aromatherapy to [ __ ] chicken don't
care did you stop self-care the chicken
i i
i need to [ __ ] okay maybe massages
aren't so bad because i feel like yeah i
think we all need a massage cool cool
with the [ __ ] down yeah jesus christ
schultz and some uh you know what i need
maybe i need some candles you know i
need to go on some boneless chicken to
calm me down after a nice argument
oh my god that stare that he's scared
he's never seen god give a death stare
before he was like
you know what maybe being a monk was a
mistake
the only thing that can break a monk is
the monkey who the [ __ ]
the mortal enemy oh my god hopefully you
guys enjoyed this episode
and we'll see you guys in the next one
bye bye boneless chicken guys [ __ ]
wrong connor
[Music]
you